Three. Two one. Yeah.
I walked in. You guys were watching
soccer. I was hugely disappointed.
England's and penalty kill. My God. Is
that okay dude? What happened? Like the,
we'll cut man, if they, when they move
on. So the penalty kick and they just won.
They just want England. Just
one. They just fucking done.
You guys rooting for England? You? I'm
English man. I'm happy English. My mom,
my mom was born and raised there,
bro. I thought what's up bro?
I know most people do English. So
you really root for England? Yeah.
Big Time. No Shit. Yes.
I don't know if us isn't in it.
You know what's happening when they're
playing or do you want me to know when
the ball goes in? No,
I have kind of an idea.
I would say I'm a blue belt
in soccer, a blue belt. Wham.
Like I wake up early and watch the games.
The only world got World Cup,
Dude, I was in boulder. You know Boulder's
like the People's Republic of Boulder.
I don't have to tell you. You're from
Colorado. You know what it's like.
I went to school. Their son bowlers
rough. Yes. It's uh, they're,
they're like super duper
liberal and people were
unnaturally happy about the World Cup,
like super excited that they know
so much about soccer and yelling.
I was at a bar and I was
like, that'll make you hate
it. That'll make you hate it.
But if you just, if you go to
England, you'll feel good about it.
But he was this certain type of white
dude. I, let's see you, you know,
I mean, well they probably had a dad
that was in the navy or some shit
got bullied around at home and they just
went the total opposite hard way. No,
that shit happens. He's a tough sell.
Especially if you're like an athlete,
like a black athlete.
Oh God. This is like,
that's what I know why
they struggle a little bit.
Like look at the beautiful mountains
are like, bitch, I don't hike.
I don't give a fuck about your mountains.
That's why they struggle.
I think recruiting really, it's so
beautiful there though. Yeah. Yeah.
If you're into fucking hiking and fucking
water rafting in shape or super nice
too though. They're all right. They
don't give a fuck about sports.
Where if you go to like a southern
school like Georgia, Tennessee,
they get pumped. God,
oh, every fucking period.
Is that bad that they don't care?
Is it good?
Like balance bat makes your
work hard. No, it sucks.
You've got nature out there though.
Eagles and shit like fucking feature
thing sucks.
You know that a wolves and bears and
wolves and grizzly bears and making their
way back into Colorado. Really?
Yeah. That goddamn time. Interesting.
Why were they gone?
They killed them off in the 18 hundreds
and then they reintroduced him to
Yellowstone and mostly they stayed around
Wyoming and Montana or Yellowstone is
and they made their way into Idaho,
but now they've definitely spotted them
in Colorado and they've also a very
credible source.
In fact,
my friend Adam Green tree took video of
what he said it was a grizzly bear and
he knows the difference.
He knows his shit. Yeah.
It was in the San Juan Mountains in
Colorado last September. So they think
that there's a population of grizzly
bears. Adam would know. He would know.
And if you watch the news, like
the local news in La, which I do,
especially when I get depressed,
you there's,
there's a bunch of black bears like a
hot tubs in shit popping up in Pasadena
chilling. Huh? Why did
they love the tubs? Well,
they don't know that it's a hot tub.
They just know it's water.
And so like for them to find a
spot that's filled with water,
it's probably terrible for them.
And once you have a salt pool,
they know how hot it is doing.
The chlorine, the chlorine,
that's what I'm saying.
Like it's a bear's drinking all
that chlorine goes in that pool.
You know what you're doing hot tub.
Yeah. That's like, that's dick soup.
Conch soup and then black mayors. Yeah.
What percentage of hot tubs to people?
Fucking 100% is the answer.
100% well in Pasadena expressly Pasadena,
they're just rocking it out there.
Yeah. There's a lot of bears up there.
There's a funny video man at this dude
in Pasadena and he's on his phone and
he's walking down an alley and as he
turns and walks down the aisle and he just
on his phone and he's looking down,
he's not looking where he's going.
He looks up and there's a fucking bear
right in front of him and the beer didn't
do shit.
The bear doesn't know what to do and
he just runs really find that dude,
homey is just not paying attention. I
would shit my pants. Oh yeah, for sure.
It's like you saw the, you saw the
homeboys in Seattle yet fucked up.
Well one died by the mountain lion. Yeah,
that's super hungry. Mountain Lion. Yeah,
just on a bike. Apparently the
mountain lion was a Macy ated.
It was all fucked up and sick and it
only weighed like 90 something pounds.
But it's still fucked. Both of those dudes
up. But they, they tell you like, oh,
use your bike as a shield and scare
them off that Lens. Like, what?
I don't give a fuck about your trek
button. They hit it with the bike.
Apparently it didn't do shit.
How about homeboy was like, dude,
you're going to attack. I'm going
to run and get help. Way to go.
Asshole runs off in that line
goes where the fuck you going?
And they can't kill him.
Yeah. Homeboy got away.
You know that happened in Beijing to with
the lady who got out of the car and a
tiger attacked her at the wild animal
park. Yeah, that's what you get.
She got out of the car. The Tiger tanks
are here to stay. Dan. That's a big bear.
Big Bear. That's a fucking
terrifying bear. So this guy,
he's on his cell phone.
Where's the uh,
that's a big ass beer. Here it is. Here
it is. Watch the dudes on his phone.
He's like, fuck. Which by the way,
the worst fucking thing you could do,
just go run. Super Lucky.
See if you could pull back.
You can see like where the bear walks
behind those bushes. Yeah, right here.
This is hilarious, dude. Look,
the bears walking right there.
That guy walks down. He's
not even looking. Dude,
you're supposed to get loud, right?
Like get as big as possible. Yes.
You definitely don't want to run away
because their instincts that have chase.
Yeah,
but they say when you get loud and like
challenge them like you hear about that,
it's fine.
I don't want him having your about that
boy scout leader know who they rent.
They solid bear and you know it's like
play dead or, or do your thing, you know,
or you know when you play
dead or get real big and loud.
Like they don't know exactly what to do.
But I bet I guess the boy scout fucking
handbook says to get loud and like make
a scene. I'm gonna Forget loud made a
scene and that beer was like, oh cool.
Hey kids watch this. Atum asshole first
and from the whole squad. Oh No. Yeah.
So they don't,
I don't think they know exactly.
Well the problem is bears are just
like every other animal, right?
Like think about dogs.
All dogs are different men.
Some dogs just come over to their house
and they're like, hey, what's going on?
How are you doing?
And it's some dudes,
you come over to their house and
dog's checking you out and like,
I dunno motherfucker. I'm
not sure about you, Austin.
They get around you and the hair
comes up and you're like, oh my God,
his hair's up the worst. Your dog has
his hair up. What's going on here?
I think bears are probably just like dogs
and they're just, they vary. They say.
It also depends where you're at. Like
they walked into his cave so he's like,
you're in my house. Give me
that ass hole. It's terrifying.
I don't think if you're that cub
scout you're like, oh my God.
Apparently the worst thing that could
happen is you walk into a female with
their cubs game over a female grizzly
with her cubs. She'd just light you up,
do you don't have no chance. It's not
like you're going to, what do you do?
I was listening to some bitch on the
news because they're talking about black
bears in hot tubs and few run
into one. This lady is saying, go,
solar's punch him in the nose on my nose.
They're noses are super sensitive or
go for the eyes. Yeah, let me try that.
They bite each other's faces.
You people have to understand like
when they fight with each other,
which they do all the time,
they do all the time.
They're always fighting for sure.
There's in person fight in the wild.
I've seen it. They just fight,
especially during the Rut,
like in the springtime,
they fucking bite each other's faces
and it doesn't even look like anything
happen. They bite the shit out of
each other and nothing happens.
So you contacting clothes
with you little bitch ass hands.
Like what are you going to do?
Cowan has an old bit where,
uh, it's, he did on a special,
so he won't mind me saying it. We count
as a little bit where people would go, oh,
just punk punch a shark in the nose.
Secure, tried punching underwater.
He's like all slow.
I've taught that exact same thing.
I've thought that exact same thing.
Like how much could you
generate underwater?
Like people go under water to work out.
You've seen that famous photo of Ali.
Ali used to do a lot of shadow boxing in
the water water and John recreated it.
Have you seen John John's one?
It's fucking dope. That's right.
Know GSP does a lot of work in the water.
He was the first one I knew it was doing
work in the water and actually for,
I mean months would drive down to Laguna
Niguel where he's working out and we do
water workouts and we're in the pool
when the pool for like two hours.
I was like Bro, I did it for
two weeks and think it, he goes,
you coming in on Wednesday and
I go, oh worst. Just the worst.
That sounds more like someone with a
mental disability from that sounds like a
rice.
I like Stephen Hawking.
Definitely sound like someone who doesn't
know English. That good. Not Good.
So anyways because you
come in on Wednesday,
I won't do that cause then again
and I was like Nah, I'm not man.
I'm thinking of fucking pull.
You'd be in there for like two hours.
He'd have these things.
You just have been doing this stuff.
He does a lot of jumping, which is
really interesting. I was thinking about,
I was like, yeah, you could
generate maximum force,
like jumping in the water and it's
probably like real easy on the joints in
comparison. It's easy
on the joints. But um,
I was listening to one
expert talk about it. Um,
actually I think Loren
Landow is telling me this,
he's a strength coach for the
Denver Nuggets, the Denver Broncos.
Now he was saying it's good to mix in,
but to do it every week all the time,
especially in the sand or water,
you're not going the same explosiveness.
You're not generating the same explosive
power. So you should mix it up. Yeah,
he goes, if you're just
doing that, you're actually,
it's actually gonna make you less
explosive. Wow. See though, she just,
B plus p begs to differ like land out.
But those dudes that are
just on the cutting edge,
they're constantly let comparing studies
and just trying to get that little
extra edge.
And it is so interesting now.
It's so like the world of strength and
conditioning has never been like more
complicated because there's no
more bro Science. They'll also,
because there's actual experts are
like, you can look it up now, right?
Like back in the day, my buddy like,
dude, just eat fucking egg whites,
which we know the terrible thing.
Just the eggs and drink milk and
get fucking swole. You wish that no.
Everyone had all sorts of weird fucking
diets or just take this Bsn enecto
explode and you'd be jacked, Bro. Yeah.
There's so many variables still.
There's still some some variables,
but when it comes to like the guys that
get paid big bucks to train top level
athletes, they seem to all be kind
of on the same page, correct? No,
Lauren Endo is one of my best friends at
plyometric stuff. A lot of plyometrics.
They all,
usually they all agree on similar things.
Like they might have this variation here,
this variation here,
but most of them agree on the
same fucking thing. Potatoes.
No one's saying you need to be power
lifting only and no one's, yeah,
no one's doing anything stupid. A
lot of them are saying, you know,
doing like Max reps and and
multiple days and all this stuff,
like that's not the way to go anymore.
[inaudible] days are over,
but I say fuck that noise.
I still do the meat head days like
sometimes like whatever fun to be a mean
Italian, get those jeans
shorts out. Yeah. Nice.
Three hour workout for
Ross was looking for Deca.
Frost was given us some insight into that,
that like his philosophy on training,
what he said it was the most
interesting thing. He's a smart,
smart man by the smartest people get,
but one of the more interesting things
that he said was that you should never
feel sore. He's like, you should work out.
You should build yourself up to the
point where you never feel sore.
It never push yourself past your
limit should never be like, ah, never.
It's like working out or training too.
He was talking about training and talking
about everything he was talking about.
Just do more, do more
of a day. Interesting.
Yeah. He was saying that if you do like
sets it like do a set at like here,
here's a for instance, I'm taking it
out of context. This is example. Yeah.
It was like if you did um,
certain amount,
I forget the numbers he was talking about,
but if you did a certain amount of work,
let's just to paraphrase,
say if you do a 20 ups and
do two sets of 20 chin ups,
he like barely can get 20 and you're
burnt out afterwards and your wrecked or
instead of that you're doing
40 reps, right. Either way,
do 40 of them throughout the day,
but do it five reps at a time,
but do the same amount of work.
How would hold your stamina?
It's a good question but the idea being,
well I think it's a different thing,
but the,
the idea being like to get yourself into
this position where you can train hard,
especially with like physical fitness
type stuff shouldn't break your body down
totally.
You should just give your body enough
of a chance to fully recover and then
build up.
I think we have to be a little careful
with it because for us specialize in
mixed martial arts where there
so many disciplines, right?
Where you can't go balls to the
wall and strength condition.
You can't just break yourself
with wrestling. You can't
just go hard and sworn.
You have to kind of monitor
those things and figure it out.
So I think it's a little bit
of bias thing. He's right.
I think as far as it goes,
as mixed martial arts,
Loren Landow has been saying that forever
cause I'd go super hard in the weight
room. He's like, I'm telling you tonight
you have wrestling, you'd be screwed, man.
Got To figure this out. You've got
to figure out this form with a man.
That was a long time ago.
Yeah.
They think that doing weightlifting and
lower reps more often is a way to do it.
Yes. It's fucking interesting man.
But when you train for a fight,
you're going to have to push
yourself, right? If you're going to,
there's going to be certain things like
whether it's hill sprints or whatever it
is.
I mean,
you're going to push yourself to the limit
and I remember [inaudible] is Bisbing
NGS. We had the same concept and trading
with both of them are busy being,
he would go so hard in
practice. I kissed his, his,
when he would warm up his
repetition, striking, hitting
Mitts, wrestling, Jujitsu,
everything was super high and they come,
this is where I get my card here from.
I'm doing the actual sport of it. I'm not
going to go run fucking sprints. Right.
Just gonna do more wrestling
rounds and GSP was very similar.
You'd go super hard in that aspect.
Yeah. GSP was a wizard with that stuff,
man.
I mean,
he was always at the cutting edge and it
came to doing gymnastics member who was
really into gymnastics with them, meaning
Mark Hart and him would do it together.
So interested in big ass. I'd watch them
do all these flips, flops, iron man,
let me try this bullshit.
Fucking cartwheel. And
they're like, very good man.
It's good. You're getting better.
You're better than fuck you guys.
Does anybody your size do that stuff?
It's gotta be some the
biggest one in there for sure.
And the rest were all eight year
old girls who are just monsters.
Nate and just pee.
I should look like this
big Shrek character in the
gymnastics is probably like
the sport that gets dudes the most
jacked when you see like ring guys tiny
though. Right? But there. Well,
do you ever seen a skinny midget, you're
skinny, small person I've ever seen.
Like a real thin, small
person. Just how, sorry. Small
Person. Uh, they're all jacked.
Are they?
No fat asses.
They're all jagged bat houses,
Bro.
I don't think it's the same
thing we're talking about here.
I'm saying the smaller, I know
they're small though. Third Jack.
Like if like if Lebron got in gymnastics,
he's not going to be Jack.
Well what's the average size
of a like an Olympic gymnast?
Five three or the really tiny,
tiny,
stocky Jack Jack.
But they've also been lifting like
that since like four months old.
All I was getting at, sorry,
before your horrific, no,
I correct this scale. Herbalist rant.
Uh, do you know what a Buddhist is?
The newest thing? No. What to say? If you
make fun of someone who has a disability,
you're able ablest including stupid
people. Tall gymnast is no oxymoron.
Okay. The average height for adult male
gymnast is around five four to five.
Seven. Johnathan Horton is listed as
five one five six five eight five.
The tallest one is my height. Five, eight.
I mean he's like the Dikembe
Mutombo tall [inaudible].
Who's the tallest? This is like the
tallest girl was like five. Two. Oh Jesus.
So that makes sense. I mean, our stud,
does it say gymnastics stunts growth?
Is that really what they think?
They start super young,
said that bright pillow that there was
an article. Does gymnastics stunt growth?
Is that a real question? Whether it's done
script, right. That's what I'm saying.
Is that a real question?
Let's see. Click it. Well,
they say lifting young stunt
your growth. Right? I heard that.
But how do they know that they don't even
listen? Why aren't you in fourth grade?
Why aren't you maybe you'd be
fucking super giant if you did.
I should have been fucking with
the gymnastics. What does it say?
Hold on a second. Stunts
growth explained. Hmm.
I don't remember tall. Maybe
there's drawn to it. You know,
maybe the short people are drawn to it.
Makes Sense.
Well for it's absolutely a myth says u
s gymnastics scientific community is an
entirely sure,
but the idea that gymnast's would have
grown to be a foot taller for they'd only
hadn't spent the time on the
parallel bars is absolutely a myth.
The best in the world is four eight that's
Simon Bio biles is four eight Simone,
some girl bro. Simone, don't Miss Gender.
Her friends call her assignments son
talking about Sim sims four April
essentially see that recovery.
That's a crazy sport man. When like
everything is like ready, set, go.
It's all about doing it in one moment,
right?
Someone says go,
you know it's there and then you have
to nail it and every a foot you have a
routine is you've got to hit a cop at
all. Came over, so over a little slip,
all those bunts and you watched
gymnastics. I'll watch a little bit.
You won't watch World Cup. I watch
World Cup. I'm just fucking with you.
I'm just sent you understand. Look, if
you, if I find out something you like,
I'm going to start mocking it. That's
how we do tell. We do, I'll tell me do,
I'm just kind of make fun. If you can
make fun of some shit that I like, man.
I like a lot of dumb shit.
You know how much dumb shit
you did bring back fanny pack.
So I brought them back strong.
[inaudible] says, yeah,
you're will get credit for you
and cro cop though. Let's be real.
You got to give Kroger Europeans less
courageous because they'd been doing it
forever over there.
But as far as you as,
as far as the u s is me and Hulk Cogan
no hope. Got Rid of a long time ago.
Okay, well we, we cross bridges. He
had it and I had at the same time,
it's like a coke relaying. What did he
let it Tom? Oh, years ago. Let it go.
Know that sex date. Can we said fuck that.
I bet he's still got one. No, no way.
I bet he does. Back in the day
at Gold's guys would have them,
they'd be steroids in those.
They would shoot up what?
Their little bag? Yeah, he could
buy it off of him. Look at that,
the hot seat and have one there.
That's pretty recent.
Those four GTECH had a shitload of
back surgeries, man. Yeah. No Shit.
Would you expect was going to happen
the wrestling he is. I believe so.
Ww eating. I heard that. Yeah.
Probably for like Wrestlemania appearance
or something. Yeah. Well that's amazing.
And Chuck Liddell and Tito are fighting,
so what else you got?
What do you think of that? Not My cup
of tea, but you know I used to watch it.
I for sure. Well, to watch it,
we'll watch campaign for it.
There's some people say it
shouldn't happen, right? No, I see.
I don't think it shouldn't happen.
I look at it more like if I see,
I think if Chuck Liddell was still
employee of the UFC getting paid $400,000
just to chill or whatever he was doing
for the USC, he would not be fighting.
I think it's more of a money play,
which bums me out because I think
chuck Liddell and Tito Ortiz,
what they did for the sports should be
compensated for the rest of their lives.
I you bumps me out. They have to
fight to make money. That bumps me up.
I don't know if Tito does so much cause
he was very smart. Chuck, you know it,
it seems like maybe that's the
what's going on there, but,
but he also has been saying,
no, you got to wonder what,
where this is coming from.
But he has been saying that he misses it
and it's the who was his favorite thing.
I miss that. He misses it. Yeah,
but it's different. Like if,
if we're going to live forever, if we're
going to live forever, I would say, yeah,
definitely don't do it because you're
just going to keep damaging yourself if
you're not going to live forever.
He's 48 so let's say we're going to live
to a hundred let's say chuck lives a
hundred homes. He's halfways
and being friendly right now.
Let's say he's going to live
to a hundred never know.
Athletes don't let us in brother.
Oh, I have another one. Am I?
I'm 35 30 solid years left to be.
So let's say chuck is going to
Madison's Sun Science. I knew shit.
I'm big though. Great
hands. Great Danes Bro.
So let's say he lives to a hundred
he's basically halfway there. Dude,
at the halfway mark fighting. It's
just, it can't be healthy man.
Like imagine me in 50 fighting Joe.
And you're the exception, you know,
like you're in phenomenal shape it.
Yeah, but I don't want to get hit.
You don't get hit in the face. It's not
going to be pretty. Not In the head.
Especially if you had all those years
of, listen, I'm not hating on it.
There's a market for it. Do
your thing. I took, like I said,
to me it's more of a sad story.
I think they should be compensated or
like I want them to parlay their careers
like a Michael Stray Han or Kobe Bryant,
you know, where through legends and
then they move on to do great
things. I agree. But I also,
if they wanted to compete,
it was because they wanted to compete.
I wonder where it makes sense to tell
them they can't or they shouldn't because
if they want to do it,
if they both want to do it,
like if they had money and they're
like, oh, so what is it about?
Is it the motivation that bothers me?
Like what is it about a fight like that
is the fee. I think it's the motivation.
Yeah. I cringe a little bit right
half a little bit because see,
I think Tito did better financially.
You know? I think Tito is fine.
He did really well in Bella Torah.
He might actually want this fight
just to fight chuck again. I think so.
I think Tito Tito's a
different trajectory. Correct?
Yeah. I mean he's been fighting
and doing well any last few years,
you know? Yeah. He's, he's
still a formidable guy.
Yeah. He's a beast to those. A big
fella. Yeah. Both. Great guys. Now,
I will say this, everyone who's fighting
in these older leagues or if they,
if golden boy, if that's your thing
to do like these, this master league,
every one fight in that league, better
pray to the MMA. God's view Bell Balfour.
It does not enter that fucking thing.
Juice to the gills. Yes, you better.
She's amazing. Fantastic.
So happy with, we'll,
we'll kick the fuck out of all those
old dudes at the same time. He really,
well dude, I was looking at his Instagram
the other day. I was like, oh my God.
Yeah,
there's something happens to veto or when
he fills up with super unleaded dude,
it's like he a butter and Jelly.
He's a different and doing roids bro.
Like some people don't, don't, don't do
well with Roy to get all red and shit.
He looks great.
His skin vibrant is tits or popping.
He's all tans teeth get wider.
He's doing straight testosterone.
He's not mean when he was on, see, think
about this, right? We know for sure.
We all know absolutely 100% that people
have cheated and taking steroids and got
away with it. We know that. I know
you know that especially in fighting,
especially when the weigh ins where the
only day you had a pee and there was no
randoms, they didn't just
come by. We know for a fact,
but when you watch someone who's just
doing testosterone and what else is doing
with a tumor growth hormone and plead
fucking gigantic now. I love that.
I love it too. But what you get
there, it's a different thing.
Like for Vituro like something
happens with him. Like when you,
when they allowed him to take it,
like during the Rockhold fight,
Bisping fight dude, his body
ate it up. But that's it.
It's a kind of a different thing because
you're, it's like it's above board.
Right. Let me let them do it so he
doesn't feel guilty about it. You feel me?
Cause he still, he's finding a
way where it's still legal. Yeah.
When he was doing it, yeah, he was doing
it legally. It was doing it leaving.
He got permission from the UFC
to do it. Yeah. The commission.
So it as much you want to say if
you go back before he did it like a,
you see when he sexy Yama. Yes. Dude. His,
his body didn't look nothing like that.
It looked like a welterweight. Right? And
everyone wants to go. A lot of people go,
oh, he did steroids with whatever sports.
Sammy Sosa, Mark McGuire, Barry Bonds.
You take steroids.
Try hitting those fucking homeruns.
Everyone was doing it in fighting.
A lot of people were doing, I'm,
I can say names if so when Jon
Jones tested hot against DC,
right? Whatever he does hot for.
If DC was doing the same stuff,
would he have beat John?
The answer's no.
What was a very close fight up until that
head kick, right? It was a good fight.
You don't, you really never
know what could have happened.
I'm just saying about high level
fighting. Right? Correct. However,
but however that's what happens.
We have to judge it based on that.
If they are taking the same stuff,
whatever you want to say, John took.
But if DC was saying, do you think the
outcome would've been any different?
My answer's no. If they were taking
the same stuff. I see the John Thing,
we've gone over this,
but we probably should go over this again.
If anybody doesn't know the actual,
the numbers,
he tested negative,
then he tested positive
for a minuscule amount,
was really small and then
he tested negative again.
So whatever happened happened in a very
short window and it was incredibly small
amount of whatever that stuff was.
Some call it micro dosing. Yeah.
It could be that. Maybe we don't,
we don't know really. Yeah.
The thing about it is that stuff is
supposed to stay in your system for a long
time.
It would be a stupid thing to take
because supposedly it's in your system for
weeks, but we don't, we don't. Yeah.
And also the micro dosing Shit
is real folks. That's real.
I mean that's what they were doing in
baseball. They were taking testosterone,
gummy bears and they would only last
like three or four hours and decided we
arrived, belies it today. Or I would
eat them during the game. Yeah. Yeah.
And then by the time the game was
over, it's out of the system. Yeah.
And baseball with that was the testing
baseball players was that dumb as shit,
but it was one of those weird American
things like everybody's [inaudible] but
if we had the Russians attitude about
this, just be cool man. If, I mean,
what is it like,
like how do the Russians feel about like
that documentary Icarus where that guy
came on and claim that all the
Russian athletes were on steroids.
They don't get to dress like, yeah,
no shit buddy. Anyways, whatever.
Let it go over it. Get over it man.
Kill a few whistleblowers over here.
Don't mind us. Come over here. Let me know
how it works out for you. Yeah, yeah. Um,
but wonder, but that's the stuff was
steroids. I think we put too much,
we almost put too much
emphasis on the steroids.
They don't get wrong and get fucking
helps and helps a lot of guys. But if,
if everyone was on the same thing,
John Jones is still be the grace all time.
He'd still on being defeated. Brock
Lesnar. It's still be Brock Lesnar.
I think Kane would still be canes.
They'd still be it.
I think everything would be
the exact same. I gotta I
gotta be serious here, man.
I think you're right.
If everybody was on,
the results would be the
same if everybody was on.
The problem is like some people
like the tour, just, it just,
his body
loves it. He's made for his
body's made for TRT replacement.
It's crazy. Yeah. So I mean, you
know, good luck. Good luck. Good luck.
Do that. Now that he's in the wild west
of Brazil and he's looking for stuff
on his Instagram, we talked
on his Instagram, he finds
his fan and you're like,
how long have you been a fan?
He's all begin and Brown.
If you want to see me fighting,
those gets goes, let's do it.
Like gives them a wink. I'm like, yeah,
who's going to sign up to fight that
fucking monster? But here's the thing.
How does he get out of his contract?
Does UFC still have them under contract
or did he retire? He retired, but that,
but just because you retired and I know,
cause I retired.
Your contract isn't void.
It's frozen. They're very
smart, but it's veto. Balfour.
I highly doubt all he's done for the UFC.
I guarantee you can talk to let them go.
I would let them go out. Assume yeah,
that would be nice if they did.
The scary thing about chuck is Dana,
who's obviously very close
with chuck for a long time.
I don't know if they're so close anymore.
Dana, this is Dana gone. She says,
I don't think he should be fighting like
I don't want to see him fight again.
I sure as fuck went limp fight here.
I hope he stopped and went on close to
the situation. So then I'm like, Oh God,
but he's going to do what he's gonna do.
Chuck versus Vituro was one of
the first fights I ever called
completed his contract with the UFC last
month and a lost Liotta Machita but it
doesn't mean he's retiring.
The phenom took to social media to hint
a return as fans who they would like to
see him fight next. Always. He's good
then. That's usual free tour though.
His choices were a bit curious.
Who is he asking a fight? Vandelay.
He asked the fan, so he said [inaudible]
Chuck, Tito, Bisbing or handle? Well,
hand on business, not
happening. Truck t door.
Manderly you're telling me you wouldn't
watch fan ugly Vitorin I would go for
that. I would watch that. What if,
so imagine of Tito and
chuck fight and chuck wins.
Chuck wants to fight again.
He wants to fight Vituro again.
Pete v tour in UFC 37 and a half and
now it's like we're back to the future.
Yeah. Text. Chuck might please don't
fight via tour. He's a fucking I fee.
I feel like it's different with, but wait
a minute, we don't know. Chuck was clean.
How about get chuck on the super soft,
the ultimum iceman sets truck
in a round 48 years old sound.
You can't be eating mangoes and dates and
fucking almond butter and think you're
going to compete with a sauce Dot v tour.
I didn't think of that.
Come on golden boy. Yeah,
you get that fucking, yeah.
You can't fuck with any
legitimate organizations.
All these with all these organizations
that want to sneak up on you in the
middle of the night and test your
key now plan, come on golden stairs.
Take a break. How about, how about, uh,
there's guys like Josh Barnett
and even Leo. Leo said,
this goes with signed with the
UFC because of you sada enough.
See they've all been busted previously
so that they have a little different.
You have an agreement with them,
but they're saying, listen.
Well Josh Barnett was not bust by right.
They came out. He never took anything.
We lost a year of his career. Yeah.
I don't understand the Josh Barnett case.
I'd like to have him explain it cause it
sounds like what I've read sounds like
he got fucked. No, he did tell
me what you know, they admit it.
They know for a fact he did not write
like they came out that same thing.
Like they've had other guys, right? Like
the, the, the dirty bird. What's his name?
Tim means he means they came out that
are bad over the counter or something.
Yeah. It's all good. Right.
It took like some protein powder that
was slightly contaminated and that came
out as true and with Josh Barnett,
it took a year to figure this out and
then they go my bad bro. Yeah, yeah.
I know he missed a year. And in
your, you know, older fighter,
it's a year of not getting
paid. My Bat, you're back,
you're welcome back now and Barnett's
gone fuck this man. I'm out.
Is that really what they did? I
promise you that's what they did. See,
that seems to me to be a case where
you've made an error that should be,
you should compensate that fight.
That's what I'm saying.
He should be fully compensated that
he should have went force a guy.
If you made the mistake, that's that's
like a, I mean I'm not a business person,
but if I was a business
person I'd be like,
well this is a clear case of someone
owing someone money because you fucked up.
But what,
what the you saw,
I was going to say it was an investigation
took us that long to figure it to get
to the bottom of it. That's the
process. But they were wrong. Right.
So if they were wrong,
so all their investigation stuff they did
that took so long to get to the bottom
of you accused the guy
who's innocent, right? Yeah.
But see they say potentially
flagged for PDS, right?
They don't say what you're flagged for
and then it goes into investigation,
but they're not, they don't
say he was, he suspended,
he taught test pilots for this.
They say potentially flagged and there's
an investigation then took a year to
figure that out. I think that
they, the, you sought a like,
especially,
uh,
under the whatever guidelines that they
had coming in here had a lot to work
with. Right. There's a lot of fighters.
You got to figure out who's he got to
test this one more tonight. I mean,
it must be crazy, but it
must be a nightmare. I'm not
saying it's an easy job. I, I,
I think it's too much a very hard job and
I'm thinking it's too much to this 500
fighters on roster,
but with a legend like Josh Barnett,
he deserves respect. That's the youngest
ever heavyweight champion. Agreed.
Joanie's.
He's one of my favorite fighters and he's
probably one of the smartest maneuver.
Grace the octagon. He's such a smart,
very smart. I love Judge Brennan. However,
if you're Novitsky and you look
at the history of Josh Barnett,
there's a reason to have skeptical golden
snitch eyes on him because he's tested
positive previously. Right. That's
what's going on. See what you're saying.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you have a track record,
like I'm going to test over him a tad
more Vittorio, tad more than steeple.
You DC, like I just look at DC,
be like, no, you're good dude.
You're fucking super unleaded.
DC. DC's 40 years old son,
DC's 40 years old on the Nash,
which is some powerful fucking genetics.
Just to get him on that super sauce kid,
Bro.
Get them on that v Tour Shit that gives
you veins in your teeth. [inaudible]
phase in your ears. Got here,
dude, killer dude. When he was,
there was a time when [inaudible] was a,
there were had to face off with him and
Rockhold and you look at Vitara like how
he was when he was doing the Mohawk to
get a sting ray hanging off the back of
his neck like a fucking sting ray
with back then. His traps were like,
they look so scary, dude. And this is
even at the Wayans man. This was when,
the way is where the real way in,
which I called told me, he goes,
you looked right at him. He's
like, what the fuck is this?
But just one straw coming
out of the eyeballs. Just
fucking tears of wind strong.
It was just testosterone.
It was just whatever they let her take
was on other things too. Oh my God.
I don't know what he was on.
It's hard to tell from that picture
cause he's an actual one 85 right there.
Oh my favorite fighters deflated.
It's amazing the difference between
some guys like when they weigh in,
like Joelle, when he weighs in at one
85 he's still looks super ridiculous.
Uber jacked at one 85 you can't believe
he only weighs one 85 and he gets a note
scale,
but then he fucking,
he mean he just puts all
that meat back on your boy,
your boy a Whitaker was like that mother
fuckers. Yeah. Here's interview is like,
[inaudible] said it was magic. He's
like, it's magic. See that man.
Go from that to that.
And he goes,
I honestly find them before and he's
aging and this time he was even harder.
He's like, something's up their
son. Yeah. Um, here's the thing.
Maybe, but you know what else may
be may be crazy. Cuban genetics.
I think that shit would be crazy.
There's young genetics,
but how much more impressive
whether whatever it is on,
let's say is on something where
it could beat him twice. Yeah.
There should not be a third fight.
I don't think this decision was just
in the second fight. Now you're crazy.
I think there should have been
10 eights. No, I think I did.
The new rules I think should've been a
draw that I don't think you all won that
fight.
If any.
If you're going to give you all a ten
eight then that's a draw or draw them and
I don't think they give drawls out enough.
I will draw them,
find her because then they're forced to
have that trust in him saying that I'm
fine with.
I didn't think that a decision.
I thought like there's too many moments
in the fight where Yo el hurt Whitaker
like really hurt.
There was no moments in the fight
where Widdick really hurt you.
Well like really hurt him.
Like had them in deep trouble.
There was one that head kick the wobbling
a little bit [inaudible] the head cake
was when Dow,
I don't think that even fucking did
much it why would his legs a tad bit.
But if you go round by round, watch that
fight a bunch. I think I was a good,
that was like he landed with the foot
right [inaudible] face top of the head.
But also like you go round by round.
I just stylistically,
I had Whitaker winning three,
two and I,
let's say I gave you out when he
fucked him up that there was a fourth,
a fifth in that I think it was both
rounds. You have him in trouble.
I gave one to 10 90 you all and
then if you give a ten eight youth,
it would still be a draw. Right? Which I'm
fine with, which makes more sense to me.
People have a hard time with decisions
when the guy at the end of the fight is
fucking the guy up.
Now obviously this is coming from
someone who's a professional commentator,
so I understand this is
a ridiculous argument,
but the ridiculous argument is if
we're going to judge what a fighter is,
we all know if you're
watching a fight fight, right?
If you and I are in a fight and you're
on top of me beating the shit out of me
in the last few seconds when the cops
come in, that doesn't matter if I,
if I've ran around this room and kicked
your legs for the first two minutes and
then you got on top of me and we're
beating the fuck out of me for the last 20
seconds when the cops can talk in
prison rules, you won the fight.
He won the fight in the fight. But
as a professional sport, understand,
but this is a professional sport
that's kind of a fight in boxing.
If I win the first eight rounds,
right, and you're whooping my ass,
nine 10 1112 it was first day. What
do we do there it is. It's a good no,
it's real good point dude. It's a
real good point. But the idea is,
see that didn't hardly all he was
on wobble. Q is already tired. Dude,
look how wobbly he is already there.
How about the kicks by fucking
Whitaker tickers? So good dude.
And the fact that he fought that fight,
most of it with a fucking broken hand,
broken him with one's brown and being
with one like the first fight gone. No,
he's how phenomenal the through that hand
to even when, Oh look, you've got cloud.
He was in trouble for Shit couple times.
I had one round of ten eight so
that'd be a draw. See this right here.
This is a ten eight man. This is a ten
eight again, even if you give a tenant,
it's still, it should be a draw. Then
maybe you wouldn't win the fight. Okay.
What draw? Two guys are
fighting. It's a close round,
but one guy drops the round,
drops him and has him hurt.
They're like everything up
until that moment. His clothes,
I think that's still a ten eight geesh.
Toss, tossing ten eight, ten eight.
It's got to be the differences.
Someone almost got finished.
This is an almost got finished
moment. The legs go, the person falls,
the guy gets on top,
starts pounded them to see.
I don't have a problem with ten nine
that I think has to be a clear fucking
bully beat down for ten eight I think
that should be a ten seven I think we
should make this shit makes sense. Game.
I mean flat white and five and 10 set.
If you gotta stop, you gotta stop slow.
I really feel like this scorecard, this,
this 10 point must system silly
the whole thing. Silly the judging,
but the silly things. Yeah,
you're right. We've been,
we've kicked that fucking whore. The
numbers. Like why do we need 10 points?
Just because boxing always had 10 points.
They're only using their hands.
They're not even using their elbows.
You know?
Just think about all the different things.
Like how what's worth more is a jab
worth more than an elbow. Yeah. Yeah.
What's worth more a gea teen choke
that you get out of how much,
how many points you get for that?
I've got to figure that out, man.
But it's also predicated off styles too.
Cause what happens if,
let's say I'm Brian Ortega,
let's take Brian and take a mex hallway
and Max Hallway on the feet jabbing good
distance control, and Brian really can't
get it going. But then he pulls, guard,
pulls guard,
and he's fucking throwing armbar
triangle leg and Max is kind of defend.
But he's in trouble. Yeah. They're not
given that to Brian down there. Right.
They don't know shit about the ground
game that they'll get Max on Tom real well
when it was on the feet, he
landed more jabs. Let's give
it to a fucking Max. Yeah.
There's moments where a regular guy
is on his back and they're right.
Correct.
It doesn't have a good guard or a guy
who just tries to hang on until the
referee pulls them off.
But then there's some dudes who have,
their guard is like the
scariest place to be.
You gotta you gotta know
what you're dealing with.
You've got you to know the premises.
You got to remember that Kid Paul Sas.
Fuck yeah. Won So many fights by
triangle, man. It was ridiculous.
You see that guy fight off
of his back. He'd be like,
whoa. Yep. He's moving quick.
He was closing shit up quick.
Dude's didn't know what the fuck was
happening and all of a sudden they're
jacked and triangled. Dude, how about
that? Max Holloway Brian or take a flight.
That's a greatest fight at 45 cents.
Connor and Aldo. Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
It's such a dangerous fight for Max.
It's a dangerous fight for both guys. I
mean this is the first, well for Ortega,
it's not his first time in
worldclass territory. Right.
He had cub and he had Frankie wolf one
bolted them in spectacular fashion I
think in this. Frankie never been
done. Never been done before.
But the crazy thing I
thought just as crazy,
maybe more crazy was the way finish cub.
He almost got cub in the first round cup
is a real Brazilian Jiu Jitsu blackbelt
free and I know that Max finished cub
as well, but cub was hurting that fight.
I think he had either a broken jaw or had
he went into the fight. Injured. Yeah,
some was fucked up. Something went
real bad during the fight. Anyway.
You know all credit to Max.
He did finish him,
but it was the way when they went to the
ground or take a locked up that Doris
at the end of the first round, I was
like, Jesus standing tight. It was,
this was tied to man when they went to
the ground and they were when it was,
when he was cinching it up and
then the buzzer went off. I'm like,
second step dad, that fights over.
That's fine. That was a tight fucking,
he did the exact same thing
again. He went, oh cool, cool.
He just knew he could do it.
The thing is his Jujitsu as
at such a fucking high level,
he's so dangerous.
You can't really train for it either,
like just just being in the room with
Dortay guts. You've seen triangles,
you've seen arm bars. The way he sets up,
it's so explosive in the angles he hits.
You can't bring anyone into
to duplicate that to me,
so different and what's crazy about Brian
says story like he's a guy who's not
going to go on and talk shit. He comes
from a super humble background and his,
his demeanor inside that octagon when
even early on his UFC career when the,
it was not going well for
him and he found some way to,
he's finished all fighters,
so found some way to get it done.
And I think it comes from growing
up in that rough background, man.
It doesn't fluster him. He's like, I
just, I need something he never gives up.
He's like, hey, something's going
to come. Something's going to come.
And I think that's huge in
this Max Holloway fight.
Cause Max distance control is
fucking second to none, man.
It's gonna be tough for
Brian to get in there.
I think once Brian can get an hook,
I think we're gonna see him jump
to half guard. Something like that.
It's going to be interesting.
It's going to be interesting to see a
Brian can turn into a Jujitsu match.
But the thing about Brian is he so
comfortable with his hands, man.
He's getting more company for sure and
doesn't train that doesn't have like a
super team. Yeah, he's amazing.
But Max Holloway, dude,
when I saw the second fight with Aldo,
the second fight with Aldo,
there were some moments in that
fight where I was like, Geez,
he's one of my favorite foods.
Dues on another level now.
But he was overwhelming Aldo. Like
he went into that fight, you know,
and the basically when they announced
the, this is where his phrase, uh,
where it started to hit me, it is what
it is. You know, as I said, I love it.
That was his attitude to go fight an
absolute future hall of Famer who was
thought to be the greatest featherweight
of all time. A guy who, you know,
think about some of the spectacular
at Kaos of Chad Mendez. And I mean,
he was a monster when he was young.
So the Cub Swanson flying knee in Wec,
dude,
he was a based and for her collar that
fight and be like, it is what it is.
Like it is what it is. The flux,
that man, he just smashed him.
Just was gonna fight.
Fucking could be. Oh yeah.
And he would've if they'd ref
if commission mission let off.
If the commission did pull him off,
the weight cut he would have fought.
Could be about like how many days
notice what was that? Eight days? Yeah,
some days when curriculum. That's not much
of a bad ass. He is super short notice.
I also think the reason why I love
this fight and so good for the UFC,
especially just for the both of them
is Max and Brian are going to fight
multiple times this I think so. I think
this needs to become a cool rivalry.
We're going to see him go
from 45 whoever wins this,
I don't really care who I love both those
men. I fucking love both those guys.
Whoever wins.
I think eventually they're both huge
for the weight class and Max is young in
Brian, they're going to go to
55 even Max's team goes, he,
he should be a 55 and he's fucking huge
for 45 well you think about how much
weight he had to lose to
get to 55 then I know he,
they pulled them off the weight
cut to 55 which is crazy.
55 there's some flight for them. I think.
And this is great for fighters, man.
Like with, with Aldo, he was never
that big until Connor came. Right?
And there's this rivalry DC,
John Jones,
Nate Diaz con like there's these Raleigh
Frazier, me shook Rhonda, there's all,
you know Holly run,
there's all this stuff starting to
happen and then people fucking tune in.
So I think for Brian and Max,
they don't need to talk any shit.
They just keep being humble.
Their skills speak for themselves,
but the people want to tune in for that.
And you're going to get a bunch
of flights out of these guys, man.
And I think you're probably right on my
Dick's hard about it. I know. I love it,
man. I get goosebumps talking
about those fucking too. Yeah,
they're pretty bad ass.
It's nice to see, uh,
just anytime you have a guy
who's defending his title
and you have a guy who you
legitimately think could be
a champion and you see, look,
you look at the two of them. Like I look
at that fight and I go, I don't know.
I don't know what's going
on. Yeah, I don't either.
I just don't know if Max makes one
mistake by capitalize on it buying so
dangerous,
so dangerous.
What's interesting to me is when I first
met Brian Gears going, he's in the gym,
remember he was mopping mats,
just doing his thing and Henry
would bring them on the road.
He even goes on the road now with Hennen.
They teach cops there,
their tactical stuff and
why they do these seminars.
And he was like Ken or
little guy and I was,
took him serious cause
Jitsu was ridiculous and he
would train with me and all
this stuff. But I never thought best in
the world, you know, I've never eaten.
Now I know I'm new. I'm like,
what's up man? And I seen it when,
when they told me, cause I caught him
for a fight and then, um, they go, dude,
you fcs come in Colorado. Not
yet. Uh, you know, I'm cautious,
Larry. I'm like, no, no,
no, no, no, no, please. He
has to work on a stamp. Don't
fucking let them do it, man.
And then Henry was like, dude, he
wants to do it. And then fucking,
I was way off that motherfucker.
He got good with his hands with fast.
He steps up to the level of competition,
man. Well, he definitely does,
but it's also,
he's so good at Hugh Jitsu that he just
took whatever that focuses that got him
so good at Jujitsu and
applied it to striking. And
now he's, he's just a winner.
He knows how to win.
You know what I mean?
He knows how to put shit together when
he landed that upper con Frankie and I
was like,
Jesus vicious frank.
He's a hard guy to fucking hit clean
in Paul's. Yeah, gray Maynard. Yeah,
it's a fucking nightmare. Well, even gray
Maynard, he came back and won that fight.
Which was insane. This is insane.
Draw on the first fight. Chaos.
I'm in the second fight. Those fights
were fucking chaos, man. Some of the best,
but the fact that Ortega took
him out and meet some people say,
well maybe Frankie's at the
end of his rope he's in,
you know he's in as deep into
his thirties now. What is he?
36 something like that, right?
36 34 either way though.
It's Frankie Edgar. Either
way. It's Frankie Edgar. Yeah,
and then he went on to beat Cub Swanson
one four weeks later or some shit.
I was like, no, I'll do that.
New Jersey. Yeah, 36 yeah,
just phenomenal conditioning dude.
And then also on this card
he got DC fucking steepy too.
To me it's like the first real,
like when the super fight here,
to me this is like the first real, real
super fight like GSP Bisping. I was like,
that's cool. That's a thick ass GSP.
I guess that's Super Fun. But DC,
Steve Bay's a fucking real super fight.
That's a real super fight. I love it,
man.
You know what?
I'm looking to almost lose four to
almost as much of Francis black beast.
That's right son Derek Lewis,
Frances and Ghana. Woo.
I know everyone thinks of me a
first round knockout in there.
Just going to throw caution to the wind.
I think Derrick Lewis double legs him
either in the first round or second round
and beats them, uh, via Tko. Really? Yeah.
Damn. How good is d Derek's wrestling?
I mean, he's the explosive dude and
you play football. You know, I, I, I,
I think people are making mistake going.
Oh Derek, just going to go on there.
Francisco, go in the fucking plant. Their
feet and just fucking chuck the bombs.
I think you're wrong, man. I think you're,
I think people think that are wrong.
I think Derek's going to mix
it up if he's smart. I just,
I think what I would do if I was them
in what Derek in his background and
Francis working on stuff,
I think Derek's going to shoot the crowd.
The crowd's going to bu,
but Derek's going to shoot and
then his grandma house little boot.
It's a good crowd crowd that understands
the danger of Francis on his back.
Derek on top. Derek with big
Kao Power Stop. Travis Browne.
I bet they might be thinking,
oh shit,
this is going to get crazy hopefully cause
it's not like if Derek takes you down,
he's just going to hold on to you.
There's going to try to get,
you know you can punch you.
It's going to try to kill.
You can face that Travis Browne
key Tko or a [inaudible].
It's one of the worst ones.
Bisbing route Dan Hendo and then that one
for me it's like you don't want to see
that replay and that was a rough one.
That was a tough one. And gather new man.
You got to get to him first.
The thing about getting to him
was you're running into hammers.
You've got to get to him,
got to get to your rotors.
Just got to kind of stay back
and then the cardio gets still.
We only saw him tired once,
but it was a big one.
You don't see them out of the
first round ones, right? Yeah.
Steve Bay figured it out. He just, he
does also steep bay. Like we're good.
I get friends, a lot of shit. But that
fucking CPA, he's the most calm, you know,
accomplish heavyweight of all time.
Yeah. I mean you have to look at him,
his accomplishments. You look at the
guys that he stopped and the guys,
he defended his title like Great
Stop Fabricio wins the title stops.
Ouster stops junior dos Santos.
I mean the only reason why Steven
doesn't get enough credit as he should is
because all these guys are a step past
their prime. Right? Like to me, yeah.
And I love Stevie. To me, what's
more impressive when Cain beat Jds,
that was prime jds.
Who was the motherfucker?
Motherfucking Cain put his fucking head
right in the middle of his chest and did
work after getting knocked
out in the first round.
[inaudible] fight in MMA history
was insane. Insane, insane.
Like that. That to me, that's a little
more impressive than what, when, what?
When Steve Bay beach jds cause the
jets JBS after an ass whooping by Kane
rounds. It is impressive.
10 of an ass whooping,
but it's almost as impressive as surviving
that first round against Francis.
I don't know who would have agreed.
There's not a lot of guys that
would've survived that round the waist.
Deep Bay did DC, DC, man, I wonder.
He ate that fucking pumped from Anthony
Romero. John, talk about that kid.
Pop the fuck back up. Yeah. Oh God.
Yeah. Jesus Christ. But John Kay Odom.
Yeah, it's Jon Jones. Jon
Jones beat everyone we're
talking about, but maybe she,
the thing about Francis, I'm very curious
to see what it looks like you no, no,
not on what I'm saying.
I'm very curious to see what he
looks like in this next fight,
but we're going to find a
lot about whether or not he's
able to correct mistakes,
whether his conditioning is just one of
those things with all that fast twitch
muscle fiber, whether he's not going
to be able to go five rounds hard,
I don't think he's going to turn into
fucking Nate Diaz or something like that.
I,
I think it might be a tad better.
The way you get better is not using
all his energy on power punches like so
maybe it's more of a experience thing.
But with Derek Lewis,
he also pedal to the metal and hits
hard as fuck too. He does and he's been,
you know, he's been in some serious
trouble that Travis Brown fight.
Like he was in serious fucking
trouble, man. Yeah, he's a,
he's a warrior for sure.
I mean that guy has been in some crazy
ass fucking fights. Crazy fights.
He's dangerous.
Both are super dangerous and he wants
that fight to Derrick Lewis has asked him
for that advice. They both won that fight.
This is going to be crazy. Super Crazy.
I think the craziest thing on the card
to me is how many people are riding off
DC? He's the underdog against Ebay.
Yeah, I have DCB Noman to you.
Yeah. I know you hate pigs, but when I,
when I break down the fight I look at
what that's terrible picture makes the
bail like super small fucking DCL giant
small STP looks DC looks like he's like
a fucking gigantic. It looks like
Brock Lesnar's do you? It looks like.
And what are they doing?
It looks like a Bantam weight.
It's all there. Yeah. One. So
76 inches. I want to 71 inches.
None of that bothers me man.
Like the reach the height because DC's
dealt with as entire career Gustafson.
Jon Jones looked,
guys had even bigger reaches.
I think also one thing to
take into consideration,
Steve Bay doesn't throw a lot of kicks.
He's not a big kicker being goes, yeah,
he's more of a boxer and um,
you know,
he's DC's also going to be able to get
under him easier than any guys ever
fought before. I mean, dcs flit five 11 to
about five alone if that. Yeah. You know,
he's getting, and he fucking, he has
top of the food chain wrestling man.
Remember when he did the Henderson
to Barnard that launched in the air,
launched them in the air. Fucking
slammed them to Barnett. Big Fella. Yeah.
And Kim grapple is fucking and
grapples fucking ass off in DC.
Took him for a ride sign.
But the Henderson fight was the most
impressive to me because Henderson,
even though he's smaller than DC,
he's a fucking stud and he was an
Olympic silver medalist himself and DC,
just rag doll dim. See? And people go,
I see some people discredit
DC a little bit when they go,
when he won the Grand Prix in strike
force, that was a different time.
Those heavyweights are
older and you know the,
the games evolve while it gets deep AI.
I'm like,
heavyweights haven't really
evolved that much, man.
You don't see a guy throwing a lot of
kicks and mixing up wrestling and Jujitsu.
Like you look at Steve Bay's game,
it's boxing or wrestling, you know,
that's very similar to
what dcs used to beating.
So the times when he's in trouble,
this guy like Jon Jones who fucking
mix up and he's a fucking nightmare.
But when you're just, when you're John
bought all, that's what I'm saying.
When DC goes in a fight and
you're just boxing or wrestling,
dcs is the reason why DC is going to go
down as one of the grapes all the time
is his mental game. Bro. You. So fuck
is he's fucking fight Iq is crazy. Yeah.
He's tough as shit. And you
know the, like if you look
who else does it the way John does,
where they're,
they're really good at everything. They
win by submission. They win by knockout,
they win by, you know, my
emails, you'd have to go,
you have to go to a lighter weight. Those
are the two, right? Because even Cain,
Cain with do moy Tai and came would
for sure wrestle and ground and pound.
But he never really submitted anybody.
No.
Kingston was wrestling and smashing
out windows. Yeah. Outwork you,
get you to get you exhausted
to the point you didn't,
you never even believed you could
be there. Embrace the grind.
Which DC has been trained with
Cain for out of this fight. Yeah.
And who is came back now. Is he a hundred
percent training? Yeah, he's helping him.
Wow. So, so when I look at
that, I go up a cane styles,
almost identical to fucking Steve Bay's,
but Steve has a little more
power as far as cardio,
wrestling kings better at
those things, man. Well,
Cain was better than anybody that ever
lived for like two years. There was there.
Yeah, there was a moment. I mean, and
he just got injured so many times.
There was so many injuries with him,
but like when you look at what he was
able to do with real fucking tough guys,
just break them down. Deal
tough guys. But you know,
he's had shoulder surgery,
back surgery, knee surgery.
I mean after a while everything was just
given out because of the force of his
will and his workouts are so
fucking tough. Those guys at Aka,
you know like Dana was giving them a
hard time at one point in time saying
something about, you know that they,
they're always getting hurt but they win.
That's how you get killers.
Like cane to get a guy
that's got that kind of mind.
He's used to being in that horrible
misery of trying to break someone.
He's used to. It does it all the
time. They all do it all the time.
And then DC went all go there and train
and remarried DC before he went there.
He trained with us in Denver. He
didn't, he wasn't that good, you know,
loves his wrestling was ridiculous.
But he moved there and then he just
followed suit. They got John Fitch,
he unconscious checked yet fucking
can be got beep hold. Yeah man.
When Rockwell gets people on the ground,
smashes him.
When he got Weidman on the ground,
widen was stuck under a building. Two,
same thing with Leo Machida. You look
at him and he'd go, Oh, branch branch,
same belt gets you down. And His
fucking top game is just murderous.
He's because of who he's training with.
He's training with those guys.
I have friends who were watching them
train down in Florida and they were just
saying, is his Jujitsu heal?
They wouldn't give me names.
They said worldclass shoes
guys. He's fucking up rolling.
Like just destroying. No,
he's a nightmare. As a freak
athlete. He's strong and he's long.
He's got like long leverage.
But he's also got physical strength.
He was supposed to by Dustin until he hurt
his leg. We'll have those official, uh,
he got a huge gash in it.
He had staples.
I think he posted it
looks fucking terrible.
That would be an interesting Justin
Kahn. Close to mirror. No time.
No time son. So you think Steve Pay
and DC goes to DC by decision? Yep.
Thank you out wrestles him.
I just think he out works them I think
yet [inaudible] I don't think it's a
classic fight. I just think hopefully
more people appreciate DC after this.
I looked at both of them.
They both have to embrace the grind thing
as as and as long as DC can avoid that
big power punch early on he's going
to be fine. And he's so smart man.
Well I definitely think he's really
smart but I also think that steep a is a
really good striker and he's a bigger
guy and he's got a long reach and he's
probably one of the best heavyweight
strikers that dcs ever fought.
He's got real one punch knockout power
at heavyweight. He throws clean shots.
He doesn't have any fat and its punches.
He'll stand here like this and drop
one in onto he credits his best shot.
He's got a chin. He's tough as fuck.
He loves being champion. You know,
he might, he might have a lot
to prove here. And you know,
he doesn't throw a lot of kicks,
but it doesn't mean he can't,
he can throw him if he wants to,
if he thinks that's part of the strategy
and he wants to throw head kicks.
I mean he would be cool to see. I don't
see him kick. I have, he can kick.
You can kick. It does. It's the
difference between kicking in practice.
I'm pulling off against a worldclass.
That's true. I like DC. Big Guy too.
Man Sees Man. And that's where
John, that's why John Jones goes,
I'm gonna knock them out by head kick.
Cause if you look at the video DC's here,
he's, if he's down there,
man, he's susceptible to it.
So that's what it sees it.
But did John fake a right hand and
then throw that left high kick?
He was setting up, he was thrown
to the body. Thrown the Mati yeah.
And then threw it out. And then you see
d say go over and then there's whack.
Yeah. I want to see if you could
find that clip of John Jones.
Kaylene DC hurt is powerful. Jamie.
Oh Man. Just landed it. Perfect.
Let me say that one more time.
Yeah.
You know what to about the, let's go back.
Go back. Sorry. Go back to the beginning.
Watch this. Fuck this. Only have
to do that. That was beautiful.
The way he did that. That was, I hope
John comes back. It was beautiful.
There was like no fat in that at all,
man. It was beautiful. So amazing. Boom.
Thank you. All good. DC is, and
for him to do that, amazing,
ridiculous smashed him.
Dude, look at this.
So ridiculous.
Damn.
It took a couple extra shots there
that he didn't need to take. Well,
there's a lot of down there and now
they're even going back at it on Twitter.
But John Jones here, here,
here's the perfect case
scenario. If you're, you know,
if you're scrooge McDuck and you're
sitting down and you're looking at the UFC
roadmap roadmap, you're like, we love
Steve Bay. He's been a great champion.
But if he could plan it like you're
fucking Vince Mcmahon and WWE,
you want DC to win.
And then John to come back
and at heavyweight you have
DC John Jones fight for a
world title heavyweight
and they have Brock gone.
I got next wait in the back on I
got next kick, kick kick you off.
Ratings, ratings, ratings,
ratings, ratings, ratings,
golden snitch. Take a hike.
I like it.
Let's let that sink in.
Another one is would have John
suspension lasts longer than we think.
We don't even,
we're assuming that John's going to get
a suspension then he's going to be able
to come back fairly soon.
Don't be the no fun police.
Well what if Brock comes in and Brock
fights the winner of DC and Steve Bay?
Let's just say DC wins. I'll take it.
Okay. And DC. DC could beat Brock.
That's an instinct. Fight. DC versus
Broxton. Interesting fight. Great fight.
Bronx got hands as big as this table.
He's fucking any Ken Russell's
ass his ass off. The question is,
cause he can he do it clean at his age
because he took like 12 different tests.
Clean talk, role clean.
We'll figure it out.
Just like the last one.
I think the UFC wants to make that paper.
You got to tell you Cyrus
scram for like dinner. One,
five k to go grab a cup of coffee.
It's broken.
John, go grab a fucking cup of coffee.
No one's going to ever let that happen.
This is what we're talking trash.
This is nonsense talk. You're crazy.
If you think you signed as all clean, like
the US government, what are you saying?
First of all, you think the US government
is clean. I'll call Eddie Bravo. Right?
That's what I'm saying. On his
way. That's what I'm saying.
You saw it as like the government son.
Everything ain't fucking done by
the books. If I'm Dana, I'm like,
you open up your glove
compartment bucks. Yeah, man.
Keep that came greasy mouth shut.
Keep agrees with these boys.
Come over and punch each other in the
face. Go fuck up our ESPN deal. Wow.
And who wouldn't want to see that?
Yeah, maybe. Yes. Pam pulls him aside.
Take them into some smokey room. Sit down
there with some Cuban cigars. It's like,
what am I doing here? Fine whiskey. How
long is their deal with Usada? Do we know?
Do we have any idea? I don't know
there cause he had signed a contract.
I don't know. I bet there's a count
down at Dana's office just every day.
365 days.
64 days.
The whole thing is kind of crazy that
it's self imposed, right Cody doing man.
Well it was a great, it was a, it's
a great move to cell to cell. Yeah.
There's the move for tea
is so genius monster.
Lorenzo's a god damn genius.
He figured it out and you know,
now he gets to just be a fan with
4 billion in the bank. You what?
What he's like, yeah, I know you have to
smash a few eggs to make an Omelette man.
But he,
it's a great success story because those
guys were down 40 plus million dollars
in the hole when I yeah,
when the ultimate fighter took off,
they had spent, they'd lost 40
million. What does that to them though?
It's enough. Forties 40 but still when
you're not, when you're, if you lost,
you lost a couple hundred grand, you
would survive. But you'd be like, Shit,
pissed for sure. He'd be
like, fuck, this is not good.
It takes a long time to make that much.
Especially when I get to my boy
to run and it was fucking up.
You know what I'm saying? Exactly.
Two $40 million is $40 million.
I'll give a five. I agree. You all
I'm appealing and I'll be like,
I don't want that money going away.
Going home. Get my dick sucked.
You know what I'm saying? Like
I'm like, God, that sucks. Anyway,
let me walk in my giant mansion.
You got to think of how many different
businesses that are run at the same time
though. They had like 20 casinos,
20 plus casinos. The stations.
They had a green valley ranch. Yep. They
still red rocks. Rocks is dope. Dope.
Dope. They just bought out palms
too. Oh Yeah, a little rundown,
but whatever. The nine though,
that steakhouse there. Oh,
that's one of the best steakhouses in
Vegas and they goes by nominal goes
probably should be dope. That's old
school. I used to stand up there.
We've done stands up, goes parts.
This is like one of the bars there.
One of the bars downstairs.
There's,
there's a laugh factory in
Vegas right there is now. Yeah.
I'm trying to bring it back
dices there all the time.
I think it's in the Tropicana.
Does that make sense?
The laugh factor in the Trump camp
and that uh, the comedy cellar? Yeah,
that's in the Rio. The comedy cellar is
supposed to be really good. Who, who,
who's running that though? Sown
sown. We know is running that.
I thought the comedy cellar, I don't
know. Um, Ian's there a lot though.
Ian Edwards. Do what? He says it's great.
Pages to me is always a weird vibe.
Obviously you're there during UFC fight.
We can do your huge fucking stadiums.
But I'm saying as far as the crowds,
usually if it's not a UFC crowd, yeah,
it's a different thing. Well, there's so
many things to do. First of all, right?
Or you can be a Celine Dion. I could
be on ecstasy right now. Why am I here?
Listen to you talk. I do want the
blue man fucking roll in my ass off.
Why am I here? There's so many
things to do, like, uh, have you,
have you ever been to one of
those sorts of soul lies? Sure.
Have you been to love the one at the MGM?
No,
but I've been Zumanity with a friend
and some drugs and it's one of the best
times ever.
Uh,
how about when Disney uses those robot
flipper things to do with Cirque du
Soleil? How crazy was that? I
posted this online. I saw this,
uh,
this,
this article about Disney's
making acrobatic robots do
these robots flip through
the air and land and jump into holes and
shit in the middle of the Goddamn Park.
These robots that Disney's
making their animatronic robots.
But here's what's fucked up about it.
What's to stop someone from using these
and making like a super warrior with the
same technology. This is all under the
guise that Disney, these motherfuckers,
I know what they're doing. So look at
these things, dude, that's a robot.
That's a robot. So look at this. Look at
it. Swing and look at it. Let go and Tuck.
Hurfeish jumped into a whole. Yeah, dude,
that's going to be a killer robot that
we send overseas to fight battles.
So look, get that thing fly through the
air and boom. This is nuts, man. I mean,
this is really insane stuff.
What the fuck they doing with this?
They're going to have this.
I like the Pixar parade or
some shift for all the kids.
I think they're going
to do this for movies,
for Shit like that so that you don't
have to risk up, man. See Ya, dude.
That is so stoked, man. Oh
my God. That's Tait Fletcher.
Tate's acting. He'll slide
in. He'll be able to make it.
He's still going to be a
character, actually. True.
Yeah. He doesn't talk to too,
but CGI a face on that ces,
right?
Paint that Disney Pixar is
painting faces on there tonight.
If you gonna need people for
Voices, half of that movie, Logan,
the Wolverine movie that he wasn't there.
There's a video you can see where they
show you how they CGI to everything.
He wasn't really there for half of it
or they act. They did it. Very strange.
That movie's depressing anyway. If
you're a Wolverine Fan. I was like,
God Damn Bro. It's driving
home limo and shit. Oh,
is that what he's doing after it's over?
He's like a limo and fucking Xavier.
Professor x is like in some weird
fucking hut dying. It's hot out.
It'll bump me out, bro. Don't watch it.
I'm not saying that movie the wrestler.
That's terrible. Yeah, it's a bumps
you out. Depressing. Excellent.
First class all the way anyways.
Yeah.
Vegas is weird as what we're getting
at in Disney's trying to take over the
world. The Disney is about to work with
Darpa. That's what's going on. Sign.
That's Boston dynamics or whatever
it is. What's the company? Yeah,
Boston Dynamics. Disney does
everything better than everyone.
He's not doing that. This show that
all breaks down. This is all a robot.
It wasn't even, it was just a stunt
double guy. What fucking haters.
Double Guy does this and then
they put him on top of that. What?
So him being a, Oh, look at
that. They just have this space.
See if you can make a
robot do all that stuff,
then you could easily just put
his face on there and Whoa,
Hugh Jackman got Super Jack Bro.
He's on that beat tour diet.
He got so swollen but he
doesn't look like that anymore.
Like in this one. No, it wasn't the
tool. America's greatest showman.
You can't be all jacked seeing niche.
Right.
So they just mapped out his face.
But the thing is like if
you see him in this one,
he doesn't look as jacked as he did.
And like the earlier ones, he's older,
he's old marine,
which is sort of supposed to be right.
If his body can recuperate from anything
when the flux, the aging. Exactly.
Come on. Why is he aging like that? Come
on where he's losing some of his muscle,
but he's still throwing people through
the air like they're attack. He gets shot,
recovers right away.
But his fucking joints hurt his arthritis.
What's happening to the arthritis? No,
no. You really moved like it these days.
I don't know if he officially does.
I'm just saying it doesn't make sense.
How about to come out with
another fucking Spiderman. Oh,
thank God they need a new spider man.
They never want to pay Peter Parker.
When Peter Parker's starts getting
big, they'd go, yeah, well guess what?
We're going to reboot it.
I just keep playing coating it.
They keep telling the same story over
and over again with subtle differences.
My Spiderman Tobey Maguire.
You fuck you.
Fuck [inaudible] Scott Chick rocks.
I'll tell you what though.
The only time that that's worked though
the hulk. Yeah, they've done that.
They started off with that Australian
dude from chopper. What's his name? Uh,
Eric Bana. Eric Bana. He was number one,
wasn't thrilled about him as the hall,
not his fault. It wasn't his fault.
It wasn't the best match script.
And then Ed Norton pretty good as a
hulk fan of ed noise. I was like, okay,
I could buy this.
But then Mark Ruffalo Best Hawk best talk,
I believe in me too,
I believe he's really assigned to,
is to really believe he
really understands genetics.
You know like Christian Bale's the best
Batman you're talking about. Relax.
I agree. Sorry, Ben Affleck. I agree.
How about Michael Keaton was Batman.
Who the fuck a good God. Damn.
Batman hygienic cast. Michael come
up this George Clooney's Batman too.
He's a fucking Mr. Steal your girl. I
bought George Clooney. I brought did you?
I didn't buy it for the second call
when Jim Carrey was the Riddler and then
Tommy Lee Joint Jones was to phase.
Those are the best Batman's
when they were like, oh,
we need to make this more
real. I'm like, fuck you.
I liked Arnold Schwarzenegger's
Mr. Freeze. Wait a minute.
Who was the Riddler?
Jim Carrey was a Riddler when?
Who Was Batman? Uh, George cloney.
No Batman returns. Broan wow. But
Christian Bale's Batman forever. Sorry.
Christian Bale is a better bet.
It's too real.
Do you know Christian Bale was Batman
only like six months after he was the
machinist. That's insane. Really insane.
Down to like almost nothing.
He was dying.
He was eating like a can of tuna and an
apple a day. That's insane. Willpower.
You have to have to let
your body literally rot away
to this skinny thing for a
movie. Just for a movie. You don't have
anorexia. You don't have a disease.
How much you love the craft of
act and to do that. Yeah, man.
Everybody trying to be the joke or these
days though. That's like the big one.
Tony Hinchcliffe. He's trying
to be wet. Excuse me. Tony.
Tony wants to be the
joker. Yeah, look. So look,
he went from that to that one 21 to
one 95. That's all natural. Insane.
There was another movie in between,
I think otherwise. Yeah. Equilibrium.
It said there's no picture here.
You're telling me that's not photo
shopped at all on the left. No, no, no.
That's what it really looked like.
That is so unhealthy. Oh Dude.
It takes years off your life. I mean,
you're putting unbelievable stress.
He's under Oregon's, he's a beast.
He's English. You know that.
I thought he was Australian,
Izzy. He thinks so.
I thought there was an Australian English
bro. A lot of them are Australian.
They'll, they'll, they'll, they'll throw
you for a loop. Jack. Chris Hemsworth,
but Jackman like as an actor,
like Christian Bale.
He does some stuff. Wolverine. Now
look, I'm a fan. Don't get me wrong. Um,
but Christian bale does some stuff
like in American psycho. Okay.
That's another one. When he
was in the fighter, when he,
when he played a Micky ward's
brother. Oh my God. Dude.
Up and down the whole time
when 85, one 21, one 91 35,
one 91 45 him and reign of fire,
he is bodied the fuck up.
So he got down skinny again to play
a Micky ward's brother. Meth addict.
Yeah. Yeah. I forgot
making boards, brother.
But his brother fought sugar ray
Leonard. Yeah. In between two rescue don.
I don't know. I never saw that one
fucking and bs. That dragon movies.
Dope for one of them silly dumb movies.
Which Dragon Movies in a dragon
movie was the dragon movie he was in,
wasn't the, in a dragon movie with
Matthew mcconaughey. If it was uh,
it was in the future. Yeah. That
everybody has to do underground drugs.
I did them all. They had to live
a fire. Oh, reign of fire. Yeah.
Yeah. That's the drag. That's a reign
of fire. There's a dragon movie. Yeah.
Matchup of Khan Hayes jacked in
that movie. Oh, super jacked to see.
He got Super Skinny for Dallas buyers club
when he had aids. Yeah, he did it too.
He's another one.
Yes.
See if you get a picture of
Matthew mcconaughey jacked dude.
I heard rumors about Tom Hardy shirtless,
but Matthew mcconaughey,
shirtless ring of fire. See
it right there. That picture.
We've got a vest on lookout. Jackie. Looks
Damn. Yeah, he was Jack's for this movie.
Ever heard of that movie?
[inaudible] it's a
dumb movie. Is it bad? It's
just dumb. It's entertaining.
It's silly. You know that these dragons,
fuck everybody up. And you know, dude,
remember how bad he
used to hate on dragons.
Do I watch game of Thrones town
on all you guys for watching?
I watch game of Thrones,
Dragon Burns. Spoiler you
fuck's been out for nine years.
He Burns that fucking frozen wall.
I'm talking about standing ovation.
I was in the middle of my living room.
Slow clap.
And those dragons are fun
and scary that when they,
the one turns into a fucking
Whitewater. Yeah, yeah. Woo.
Card into is. I just feel,
and it's a white walker. I,
everybody who works on that show,
listen to me, don't ever cancel it.
Just keep going. It's just, you never
going to do anything better than that. Oh,
that's the greatest show of all time. I
know. I don't know what you're thinking.
Just write some new episodes.
Figure out some new shit.
It's the greatest show of all. They just
rap. No, they rep. No, there'll be back.
God Damn. Look at that. Miss Jam.
I'm mechanic jacked Jack Cheese.
I feel like for me to get that skinny
and thin, I would have to go on some,
I'd have to get some roll like
Dallas buyers club and blew it up.
One right above that. Right above that,
right above your cursor. Right there.
Right there on different, Oh,
who's that? That's Bradley Cooper.
Cooper body dumped to him son.
Look at him,
but wouldn't you get do all of
the steroids to play these roles?
I think they call me to be Batman.
I'd like, yeah. Yeah. All right.
Let me go down at Gold's gym. See what
I can do. Yeah. You would have to.
You'd have to, you'd have to go on the
carnivore diet. Drop your body fat down.
I wouldn't you though.
Intermittent fasting. Just the
whole cryo every day. Yeah.
You'd be training camp.
Get shredded training camp.
You would want to have that scene where
you're putting on your fucking outfit
and you're just talking like we need
more scenes. Where at mom's short list.
Just town downtown bullshit.
Oh,
Ryan Reynolds. Ryan ramp. Is that
Ryan running blade blade blade three.
That's Ryan Reynolds and Blake three blue.
Who is that guy sees another guy
that's, oh no, that's next level.
See if that's what you gotta try for.
That's what you gotta try it for.
No one ever tries to that.
Do chicks don't take that though.
Other dude's Dick fucking mouth.
We take that shy girls are like,
no, I don't like they say that because
they're trying to make you feel better.
Oh my God. I think it's so gross.
I like geysers soft like you.
I like to grab your back and fill out fat.
Okay.
Brian federals with this fuck no bro.
Pack.
Oh my God. No Way. I mean,
I definitely don't bond
his dick in my mouth.
A little belly fat on my nose.
Full rack of ribs.
No fuck in the shake once you're
done with this shit like a man.
He was just a real lax like me and doesn't
want to deal much. That's what I like.
Please do. They're trying to make you feel
good. We'll try to make you feel good.
I'm pretty good saying,
I'm not saying you are fat.
Were both fat compared to that guy,
dude.
Both of us are fucking Adele compared to
that guy. I'm saying that's unrealistic.
Like dope. Like that's too much.
Someone has body image issues,
girls to get planes about chicks with
little waist and big tits. Oh my God.
I have body and it shows. I appreciate
it man. More than people think I'm gay.
I appreciate you have any body image
issues because of these women that are
unattainable. They have these
unobtainable bodies and it's filled up.
You're putting a standard on women that's
not real. Yeah. Yeah. I have that framed.
One sweat. I had a friend once who
said this, she was, she was uh,
talking about someone's
girlfriend. She's like, Oh,
I just wish he had a real girlfriend
or like a real, a real woman. I go,
what are you talking about?
And she's like, oh look,
look who he's dating is typical pretty
girl with blonde hair and a nice body.
Like what? You know, why doesn't
he have a real girlfriend?
I go put heats up the fuck I'm, and
it's so crazy. People are real people.
Like everyone's really,
you're,
you're hating on someone because they're
a trust not you. Yeah. Yeah. I come.
Why would you assume that she's not
super nice and really friendly and really
smart?
Cause you're prejudice because you just
looking at her and deciding that you're
hating it. She had dumb ass
probably. But does that matter?
You know what I'm saying? It
does not matter. It's all right.
You might not be as smart as you. How much
is that? How much of that is her fault?
I've, this is as I've gotten older and
wiser when even when I meet dumb people,
I'm like,
how much of it is really their fault?
Maybe they're just not into that stuff.
Maybe they just got a bad roll of the
dice with life and with genetics and the
whole ball on top. Sometimes a bad roll
the dice is you're genetically gifted.
If you're a girl or a guy and you look
super pretty and things come easy to you.
You never had to read a book or get
balls deep into a sport or something like
that. And that's, to me, that
can be a curse. Yeah, dude,
there's a curse to that because
then things get easy like you want,
you want your daughters, you
don't want to be tense. You want,
I'm like sevens strong, seven strong
seven where like guys like didn't like,
there's certain guys types, they still
got to educate themselves. You know,
like you don't want to blot asses and
big titties. You want him to just like,
you know, you know what I'm
saying? Oh yeah, for sure.
You don't want Nikki Minaj
is your daughter in that
10 to tens of sprint seven
is a ultra marathon. Yeah. To
me, seven to have a long day.
A seven for many, many, many years.
Especially like h and r block go
to the gym. They can hang in there,
but they gotta work for it. Like you
don't want to just give it to them.
You know what I'm saying?
The problem with some tens that
go to eights can't handle it.
Even when they're eight they're still hot,
but in their mind,
but in their mind they're not anymore
and they get real freaked. Rosa,
no test to Testarossa.
It was hot in the eighties so long this,
that's when they had the gated shifter.
Yes. You drive one down. You're like,
what the fuck is going on?
Oh,
stupid Fred Flintstone could get on until
I have to get out and do this now let
me one of the worth like $1 million or
something just to try and bind one. Yeah.
Did you? I wanted one. I'd
go on these weird fucking,
I almost bought a Delorean the other day.
I knew a lady who had an old Ferrari.
She bought an old Ferrari in like 2015
she bought like one that was the one from
Magnum Pi. Oh, the three 64 is
that what it is? I think so.
Is this cool little car,
but it was always breaking those things.
They're just not gonna. It's
not, you can't drive across
country in that car. No.
You don't have somebody who's in driver
every year. Yeah, that'd be fun though.
I'd like to have a bunch of cars.
I would like to have a bunch of
cars to half a bunch of Co. Yeah.
Don't jump into this company. I'm
still hustling. Don't try like, Hey,
don't try to the dude.
You're fucking Hudson your ass.
I'll put you out of all the clothes.
I don't have all the cars.
You know what I've been getting into man,
old plain looking BMW m
threes like an e 46 Mre.
Wow. All right. I'm down for
that. You'd get an eight series.
Would that be 12 maybe,
but I'm talking about what holds cars.
I'm talking about like a 2005
me to have that eight series.
I'm talking like 1994 but those are for
12 that's when the lights go up has been
sick. That's where I draw the line.
When the lights go up, can't do it son.
Testarossa of the BMW you like
deal with the the 95 three series.
Kim, that Canary Yellow.
I did. I did like those.
I like the ones with the big weighing
in the back of the m three with the wing
on the back. Tiny ass little car too,
man. You go near those cars today.
They don't make anything that
small anymore or not know.
BMW doesn't at least look at that.
Those white lights on the side.
So that's a dope look. And that's an
[inaudible] 86 right? That's an e 36 BMW.
Yeah. Yeah. Google a silver.
He 46 BMW. You're thinking
about getting one of those.
I'm thinking I don't have
all the cars. I know, right?
Well that's because valley guess. Yeah.
Are you going to buy it to run into,
look at, look at that. I like that.
You know what I like about that?
That's not that. That's on 95 yes,
it's 2005 what I like about that. Yeah,
that's not 2005 [inaudible] 46 back
stiff. Yeah. No, not supposed to.
What they look like?
That's an m three that's exactly it
looks like I'm a fan of the model.
It's a very plain looking car.
You just,
so you know what some
people do with those?
They just juice the shit out of the
engine and change the suspension.
And the thing about it, it's a light
small car that like moves. Well,
I think that car probably only weighs
about 3000 pounds. Like Google.
How much does a 2005 BMW m three were?
Those portions are layered
as fuck too though, man. Uh,
just Google. How much does
it weigh? Was the weight.
I mean, we could go buy 10 of these
right now, Joe. No, no, no. The two,
3,400 pounds. So that's a pretty
light in comparison to like a new one.
I bet the new ones are three or 400 pounds
heavier than that. That's a big deal.
The new ones are way fast wave and way
too fast. Way Too fast. Way Cooler.
The spiral. They take these and they
put crazy engines and oh they belonged.
Juice them up because it's a smaller car.
That's one of the original like cars.
I remember kids just fucking Jack and
the big exhaust on you buy the shirts.
Do you ever see a kid who just spent so
much money on a really shitty accord and
puts Chris Civic and we grow
just as they sell it at pepboys?
Doesn't mean you have to
put it on the Goddamn car.
Why do you have all that shit all over
the car? What are you doing and why?
And it was so loud. I'm like,
Kirsten, even fast. It's [inaudible].
I have that horrible four
cylinders are all fucking nuts.
Those kids thought they were so cool.
Well I guess it's cooler
than the car as it is. No,
probably not even cause what
it is is just transportation.
It's supposed to just accept what it is.
It's peacocking like,
like look at this again.
You're not doing it for girls.
He draw up for dudes. Other dudes like,
oh, that's pretty cool. Girls got,
what the fuck is that thing?
Yeah. Look at that Honda Civic.
It makes my dick go limp like that.
Like a civic.
They can make those things fairly
fast though. Campaign. Yeah.
I do start into the Sii ones
you're talking about. Yeah.
What does that Ford Focus Gt?
Is that that little tiny
car go fast as fuck. Yeah.
That's a tiny little concert like that
though. You want that Subaru WRX STI.
The Ford F. Yeah. How much does that thing
way though? That's a tiny little car,
right?
That thing looks like shit.
[inaudible]
does. It does. 3,200 pounds
is a tiny little car, bro.
Dude, you brought up 95 BMW's
Ford focuses and civics.
Well, you know man, you know I have that
white car though. The white nine 11 rs.
Fuck that car three ruins me for
everything else because it's so light.
They're crawling away is 3000 pounds.
That thing's insane.
Ruined me for everything else. Nothing
else fun to drive. Everything's fun.
I love car. Didn't, that thing
is just a different animal.
It's like the difference
between like a dog in a Cheetah,
like one of them was like dogs run
pretty good, they do a pretty good job,
but then you get cheated and
you're like, Jesus, what?
But what if you got him a dog?
What if? Yeah, it's a weird,
but what if he got a nine 11 t how lights
at nine 11 t and then soup the Senate
to shark where it's just a blow they ass
out the front. Oh one of the new ones.
You mean the things light?
It's fuck, they're very light.
Yeah. The nine 11 teaser.
Yeah. I'm sure they could do something
like that because they don't even have,
you know, they don't have handled,
they have nothing there. No backseats.
They're super light. Yeah, they, what
did they get them down to? I forget,
but is it gt three weights there? I want
to say they're lighter, aren't they?
Gt three touring package gt three without
the crazy wing and it just cause which
most of the people are not
taking them on a track.
You just driving a fast car around
town 35 I can't have that thing.
So the GT 200 is this the
GT three or this? The uh,
the t 3,200 that's pretty God
damn light for a Porsche. Yeah.
Zero to 63.4 seconds. Yeah, but you
can soup that fucking thing up. Yeah.
I wonder what is the a horsepower,
what does it say?
Okay.
See the, what they're doing with, yeah,
that's a three 70 and that's not even the
s engine. No mass. The regular engine.
The salts turbo. Now though,
go to nine 11 gt three touring.
I bet that's just as light.
But that's got like 500 horsepower.
That's my next ride. Either want that on
glare. Glaring man. But you have that gts,
which is a very fast car too.
There was a, it's fucking great.
[inaudible] there was a big article about
one of those recently. I know people,
they say it's that one of the
best like daily drivers, Porsche.
How that's 3,100 pounds
son [inaudible] 500
500 horsepower, 3,100 pounds.
That thing must be amazed.
This is what I want to do.
Only get a torn,
I want to order and I want in that mint
green, they've got pretty, that is,
they just nailed that shape.
You know?
I love it if it's one of the more
interesting things about cars is just the
physical shapes, like what they've
managed to like make iconic,
like the Porsche is such an iconic shape.
They don't need to do anything.
They'll do little subtle changes
to the back and the exhaust.
That doesn't bother me. Yeah, they just
keep kind of tweaking it a little bit.
They keep that shape like every nine 11
looks like a nine 11 like if you look at
a 2019 Mustang and then you
look at it in 1965 Mustang talk,
how do I know this is the same thing.
I know could barely tell
this is the same thing,
but you could have a nine 11 next to
like you'd have that that nine six four
that's like a 91 next to a
2019 and you'd go, I see.
They're both fine.
Eleven's 100% yeah.
That's the only car that I can think of
like that because old Ferrari's don't
look like new Ferrari's at all.
Not at all.
I guess the new challenges looked like
a little bit like the whole challenge.
That tab. Yeah. They retroed
it out a little bit. Minerals,
they're trying to go back to it.
Can we count Sky Camaro's did like
a new take on it at the newest ones.
Even look at that Sun.
Come on though.
That is a gt three rs in all green.
Seinfield gets like those and shit too.
That's an amazing car, man. That's
cars more than 500 horsepower.
I think that things got
five 20 and they're,
they're so light and that just
design track. You like that?
You think you're a dick head for driving
around town? Oh yeah, for sure. Why?
Draymond green of a lime green card
that says gt three Rs on it through Mike
says gts and it's fucking hot orange.
You should only wear a golf club.
Shirts from exclusive golf club,
golf clubs that no one could join.
If you try that and then have
those loafers on with no socks.
Smell like audio,
just beating the shit out.
You should smell like a,
what's that?
What is it called when you might pass
down money to your kids and they have one
of those accounts were drugs found
trust funds. That's it. Smell.
You could smell it and trust fund.
That's a f. I'll tell you what, man.
It's like all the handicaps you get in
life when the biggest handicaps you get
is a trust fund. There's something
that happens to kids, at least secure.
The ones that I've ever heard of,
not just security,
but a large income just given
to them by their parents.
I still have to work on it. Yes. You know,
I read a statistic that it's like they're
400% more likely to die before they
just 40 when they have that much money.
Jesus,
4% 400% I know a couple people that have
had one of those deals where they had
one of those and did you like
them? Now they fuss. They felt,
I felt sad for them. No. I know.
It felt like they were, they were.
They weren't really done.
Like if you're an egg and you
still got that gooey stuff on top,
it's like it's not quite done.
Rich kids are counting on inherence
to pay for retirement will offer young
people. Hold on. Where
are you going? Well,
if young people say they need money
from relatives and friends to guarantee
their golden years, stay gold. See
that's just click baity system.
Click Baity Shit.
I just saw this article the other day.
You guys just mentioned
it as like 63% of them.
Then the panel was 63% of affluent
children between the ages of 18 and 22 say
financial stability. Retirement would
depend on inheriting money. You know,
it's just,
that's one of the things that Tim
Kennedy said when he was on the podcast.
He said, hard times make hard,
man hard man. Make easy times,
easy times. Make soft men and worst
and Kennedy to preach. What do you do?
What do you do with your kids?
Like my kids growing Marshall
Armonica martial arts for the girls.
You think going to be balls
deep in martial arts? They're
like in ninth grade. I,
no, just to get, I think you,
you got to get a certain amount
of like actual hard work in,
in your life or shorts going to do that
for him. I think there's something to it,
there's something to goal, uh,
like valuing goals and, um,
to working towards things and then
being in difficult situations.
We can help kids. Sports. Yes.
Sports in general. Yes, for sure.
I think all sports, but I think Marshall
Marshall articular it's more personal.
Like when someone's strangles you and
somebody gets your back and then sinks
that fucking body triangle on you and
you're fighting off and then they get you
and you have to tap. That's very
personal. You'll get humbled for sure.
But most people don't deal with
those kinds of things in life.
I think the experience of dealing with
those things in life is very valuable
because you can relax more.
They could relax more. You know,
there's some people evidence. Yeah. Well,
it's not just that you've
experienced bad things,
bad things in terms of like
bad, uh, defeats losses,
getting smooshed, having to tap. There's
a lot of people that have never occur.
Many times you have a role with the guy
that never rowed before and the moment
you start rolling with him,
you get him on his back and they
start hyperventilating, panicking.
They panic because he never been there
before. Professional football players,
basketball players, I've rolled with them.
They get down there like, oh shit, oh no.
They realize they can't get up and
then you start closing the gap on him.
Here's the problem with my only
problem with Marshall active,
if you're just going to go down that road
is when you're in that Dojo where the
fuck you're doing the martial arts, when
they leave, they know that they're not.
Many people have seen it,
right?
Like if you and I are rolling and we
don't know each other, you tapped me out,
I leave. They're not too
many people see it the other,
I see it when you're professional
sports and we're playing basketball or
football and the game's on the line and
I get embarrassed cause I dropped the
ball.
Why?
Whiffed and struck out in the entire
audience sees it and I have to deal with
that and then come back from it and be
like, all right, I can deal with this man.
I've, I'd fucking struck out.
I play a game next week. Right.
I got to go through class.
People are gonna make fun
of me. I'll figure this out.
To me that builds a little something
different yet it's also teamwork. Right.
That's a big part of life. Part of lives.
Being able to work with other people.
Yeah.
Being able to perform under pressure but
also facing that adversity and no one,
cause if you tapped me out, Mike
McMahon, when I go to school,
no one knows that that's
whatever. When I, when,
when my class knows I threw an
interception and like fuck shop threw that
interception man. Monday. Everyone's like,
dude, what happened? Like I know, I know.
Wait Til Friday. We'll see. What
happens Friday. Oh yeah. Um,
Bill Buckner had to leave Boston.
You have to go into like fucking,
he had to go into hiding.
The ball went between his legs.
Everybody freaked out dude. I
remember people walking around, dude,
people were walking around
the neighborhood while
that was like try and find
kicking the snow and angry.
They were just so angry.
People were leaving their houses.
It was like there was reports of it
all over Boston that people just slant,
they couldn't deal with it anymore because
then they would just slammed the car,
the the the front door rather and
just walk out into the street be like,
what the fuck?
Just to tie out there smoking,
looking at each other like how the
fuck did he drop that ball? Dude,
imagine you'd be that guy. Tragic.
Look it. All of it is rough.
I think sports are definitely great
for, for kids, for anybody developing.
Even for adults. I think they're
good. I think competition is good.
The problem with people
is they, they, they,
they get nervous about trying new things
or doing things and I think one of the
things that gets you over nerves is
having done difficult chip before.
And one of the things about Jujitsu is
that that's such a claustrophobic feeling.
Like when you're,
when you're locked up in a triangle and
you're just trying to get like a hand in
there to protect,
you just just try and you're feeling
the squeeze and you're like fuck,
I might have to tap. And you try
and you make your way out of it.
That being able to do that in your life.
Like knowing I've been in a bad
spot before knowing I've been,
someone's been on top of me before
and I didn't think I'd get up.
I think it's a very valuable thing for
people to experience and I think it's a
good thing for people to learn.
Like,
if you could start out as a white belt
and just deal with that stuff that you
get up until like blue
belt and purple belt.
We start developing some skills
and putting some tap sound up.
If you can get through that man you can
get through anything a guy can get to
purple belt or a girl can
get to black belt or brown
belt. Those people, that man,
that woman that can get that far, they
can do a lot of shit. God Damn Bro.
That a lot of people can't do
for sure. For sure. For sure.
I think giving your kids
that opportunity is,
is a a massive thing, you know and I know
your kid's going to learn how to fight.
How the fuck is [inaudible] you alright
cause you know I watched a lot of fun so
I came in the house whenever
I want to get home today.
Hope cause he sees all the fighters,
boxers and UFC guys.
They fight with their shirts off
and I walk in, you just pop up,
pop up pink shirt authors.
I'll show you video of him hitting Mitts.
I'm like, I don't know what to
do. Get encourage him. Yeah. Time.
The don't you tell him not,
don't you don't have to fight son.
He only does it kind of made good. Yeah.
He only does it with me. Goddamn hit five.
You're not getting hit in the
head that he's toying dead.
He's on the road rolling out.
So,
but like have you seen any Bravo's
kid do martial arts to seen hunters?
I haven't. I'm going to focus on
a teddy bear kind of just post.
He's on a teddy bear doing like
armbars teddy bear and he's a,
you know Eddie does drills with his kid.
He posts videos of drills
he does with his kid.
His kid has no learning the system.
I think that's good. Fuck yeah,
his kid's going to be an assassin.
You know what kind of Jiu Jitsu
Eddie Bravo's kids going to have?
Pretty gnarly because he's
around this kid all the time.
Like Eddie is a diligent father.
He loves that about dad.
He [inaudible] get some
mount this shit ghetto.
That is hilarious.
He takes the back look at that.
He's like two and a half on this.
That is hilarious.
This kid is taking the back at
two and a half. That is so funny.
This is hilarious. The best teacher
in the world. Of course. Yeah.
That's amazed on explains about it.
And I think Ken or two,
this is like his biggest
pupil in terms of a Jujitsu.
I mean obviously Ronda Rousey was his
most famous pupil that aren't by that.
Kids got that. Rhonda had an arm bar
before she got there. She did exactly.
But Brian or take as everything,
he's got everything he can choke.
You could take your back and
you fight you off his back.
Brian came in there and
didn't know anything. Yeah,
it was a tough gang member.
Want to be? Well, I shouldn't say wannabe
was a tough gang yet from the streets.
Couldn't afford it. So a Henna took
him under his wing. That's amazing.
And now he's one of the,
you know, he's number one.
That's a middleweight in the world, not
named Max Holloway. That's amazing. Yeah,
it's a cool story. And are such a good
instructor, man. I love listening to him.
Talking to, he's so enthusiastic as a
contagious, you know, like videos online.
She could sell anything. We're going to
make watermelon juice guy. So I, Oh shit,
this is what we can do it. You're
like, okay, watermelon juice. I've,
I've had a lot of coaches since I was a
very young kid and I've never had anyone
as far as like a better coach than Henoch
grace. Wow. I know, man from the source,
man. I mean, think about that. Yeah. But
there's of those guys from the source,
but they just, they're not, they're not
Hanner and all those guys are great.
But as far as like,
as far as egos and just being like a cool,
like you and hang out with Henry anywhere
and he's like a great Todd's office.
He knows a thing or two about everything.
Like he's like, did you say surfing?
And he has a black belt in
serve fruit. You know, sue,
she opened up his own place. Now he
has his own Jujitsu place. Yeah. They,
they left his dad's place. They went
right up the street. Now him and his, uh,
here on Huron. Yeah. Oh, that's amazing.
So they shut down that and it's right
up the street still in Torrance.
Very close. I'll have the facilities.
Ridiculous. Is the old place still open?
Hines got down. I'm not sure. I'm not,
I don't know the details on that, but I,
I know Hannah and Huron on doing their
own thing on. They're killing it.
That's awesome. Yeah, dude,
it's very lucrative in southern
California to think about how many Jujitsu
schools, especially if you're, I mean
Henna and here on top of the food chain,
but as far as business mind to, that's
what makes her so special. His business.
Mine is insane. Yeah. He
started the Gracie University.
That was all his concept is
they're willing. He came up
with that. Well, let's see.
Oh, someone who lives in the middle of
the country. That's a great thing. I mean,
it's not as good as being
instructed by Hammerstein,
but if you live in the middle of the
country and you don't have to other
instruction, that's a great
note in Wyoming or some shit,
and you can go online and real place
snowed in my will. I do snowed in. Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
Sounds like your town though.
He's played does like a ski resort. I
don't, Snowden noted. Noted. Oh yeah.
We go to Snowden every year with the
McGraw. I love snow. Did we fly Snowden?
We fly together. Drink
cocktails. It's amazing. No done.
We're going to Snowden.
I'm going to wear my far.
I don't care where my fire for Peta.
It sounds like a legit place. Yeah,
it does. Have you ever been in
Wyoming? I've been to Wyoming, yeah.
Do I just went to Idaho for
the first time. I was just, Oh,
you met the black rifle guys mast. Great.
Got Great to see. They're all great. Yeah,
they were awesome. Did you go
hunting with him or no? No, no. Oh,
well those mother fuckers humans, but
yeah. Hey, that's not what I want to do.
I'm just saying it's like, you know
humans. You can hunt elk or, yeah.
A lot of those guys who used
to hunt humans become hunters.
It helps them sort of cope with
society. They also have, you know,
they have a special skillset. Yeah. It
was a little bit very good with the guns.
Not even with just guns. A lot them
get into bow hunting and a lot of them,
a lot of that. You and Matt would get
along. Great Guy. Great Guy, right? Yeah.
And the coffee's bad ass
man. It's delicious shit.
And I got my own Coffee Cup.
I don't know. That's what I heard. Kid
Black Rifle Coffee Brendan shop version.
Were they calling it the
big, big, big brown coffee?
Smiling Bray about big brown blend. I like
that too. With the Big Brown Coffee Co.
I liked that too. Via Brown
car rifle. Yeah. Nice. Your
own grand. I know. Damn sign.
I know. Ranching out here. Like a, what
are those things? Entrepreneur. Yeah,
I guess I got fucking boss,
businessman type care. Dan. Fuck dog.
Idaho is nice dude. They said the show
is fucking great. It was really fun.
It was a big ass place. Is
Big theater down that side?
Yeah. It's where the UFC is.
U of C's there in July.
What car does that? Um,
that's junior Joe Santos versus dude,
he's fighting that Russian lead character.
Who's he fighting that off yet? No,
not Volkov new. That's the talking.
Forgot about Volkov. I know.
Darkest of dark horse. What's
that? Even off, isn't he? Um,
wasn't he the guy that was the belt
or champion at one point in time? No,
that's full cub bro. No, but I
think he was first. So it goes,
yeah. Black Golf, ignorant black
glop. Ivana. Ivana of, yeah,
black boy Yvonne off. I think
he was, um, just Google him.
I think he was, uh, he was either a
world series of fighting champion.
Might be that we're, I think you're right
on world series. That's not built tours.
Is it? Maybe world series
of fighting. Let's see.
Oh, he's world series. You're right.
He's world series of fighting. Yeah.
He's a tough mother fucker. That
kinds of crazy story too. Um,
he was stabbed and he almost died. See
if he could find that story. It's a,
it's a crazy story.
Got their mean Juhas no favors.
He was stabbed I think more than once.
I'm pretty sure this is the guy, but just
to just Google his name and stab. Sure.
You're not talking about Darren
till no, no, no, no. Darrin tells,
well he needs to be Marie as
well. Everybody can stay. Yeah.
A lot of people got stabbed like against
that, but I think he got stabbed. Yeah,
he got stabbed. The God. Yeah, I'm
serious. Let me see. Bell Tours. You see,
did find Bell Tor to
Ivana reportedly stabbed in the heart
clean to life support, right? Yes.
This was like 2011 what year was this
sweet memories of fighting champions.
So good with shit that I
shouldn't even know. Um, yeah,
he got stabbed in the heart.
So he fought for Bella tour and then he
went over to world series and now he's
in the UFC and his first fight
is junior dos Santos. Damn. No,
that's not his first fight.
No, I feel like he's fought
already in the UFC. No Way.
That's his first fight. Is it
okay. My first fight for sure.
I must be thinking about the
world series of fighting. Yeah,
that's his first flight. Cause he
thought Josh Copeland World Series.
He's a tough motherfucker. This
guy though. Very tough. Tough.
It depends what junior
we get, you know? Right.
And this is junior and that also had a
Usada scare. Something happened with him,
but then they let them off the hook.
Right. I don't, we never hit right.
That lets us, to me, that's the
problem with you. Solid as they go,
this guy flagged. But then if they
get, you know, proven innocent,
there's no big writeup.
There's no big announcement.
Like there should be a fucking,
maybe didn't really proven
innocent. Maybe it was,
um, wasn't a diarrhetic or something
like that. Yeah, it was diuretic.
Maybe didn't get proven innocent. I
mean, what was the last time he fought?
Maybe he just hasn't fucking grizzled.
Steepbank yeah, that was steep.
It was last fight. How long ago was that?
May of last year. It was a good fight.
So how much time do you get suspended?
It depends what you're up, but six,
12 months, right? Depending
what you took. Right.
But if you're going to take a diuretic,
is it the same as taking Jews like that?
He took a steroid. You get longer,
right? Yeah. Hm. It's all weird, man.
It's almost,
it's almost confusing.
It's like what they say about
the Tour de France tour.
France knows how it's pronounced. It like
Brian Cowen would appreciate that too.
De France Tour de France,
they say that it's healthier
actually to do that with drugs.
Those do without drugs. It's so brutal
in your body then when they take, yeah,
and we taking fighting's the same way,
like it's so taxing on your body. Yeah,
that was my point. Yeah. I mean,
I really do, but I didn't want to,
I wouldn't want everybody to
say they have to be on it,
like everybody has to be on it.
I wouldn't want me,
that seems like maybe we shouldn't do it.
If you have to do,
and just Santos admits
he's still scared of Usada.
I won't say it doesn't bother me. Hmm. I
wonder what the actual, he was flagged,
but he was a proven innocent.
That's insane because we don't,
there's no huge announcement about
it. See, that's dangerous. Right?
Because if that, I mean, how long did
he get sat out for a month? It said,
and under. He hasn't fought since then.
He wants to fight again right after c,
but you're,
you're guilty.
It's like if a girl accuse you of
sexual assault right off the bat,
if that goes on Twitter, you're assumed
guilty with these guys. It's, oh,
he's a drug user. But then I had no
idea he was, yeah, I have no idea.
I had no fucking clue.
I know.
I saw the announcement that making
that final oh yeah. Always back.
Who was he supposed to fight though?
He was supposed to fight someone else
and it got rescheduled, I believe.
Am I wrong? Was Sing dollar? No.
Is Francis Right? Oh, Jesus did.
He's supposed to fight Francis. Oh, it
was in September and fun. Oh my God.
The one thing I wish the UFC would
do better, even this isn't the UFC,
but it be great if they did
announce when a guy's vindicated,
when he's good to go. Yes,
I need a fucking celebration
like this little birthday.
So they're, they're good to go. The
other thing is when guys retire,
like so many guys retired,
like let's do something for them.
Like guy like Rashad Evans, UFC hall of
Famer. One of the best guys to ever do it.
Great Dude. He put the UFC on the map.
Let's do something which they do for them.
I need fucking something or
celebration of his career some.
So it's just I need something, man. You
just can't go. Yeah. Thanks for the Times.
Here's a tweet. I just, I don't feel
like that's right. Not for everyone,
but for a guy like Rashad, we need
something won the ultimate fighter.
One of the light heavyweight title
think of is rivalries with a fucking Jon
Jones. Jon Jones, Quentin Rampage
Jackson. He based being too tough.
Fighters never fight like he's
had some crazy times. Now.
It's funny, man. Fighters,
people think about you as, you know, your
fights. You have late in your career.
They forget that crazy fights that he had
earlier in his career. Oh my God. See,
I think the ones that he was doing
these paths, whatever, four or five,
which were tough to watch, I don't
think of her shot like that. Yeah.
He's a different guy and there's something
that happens to fighters or to human
beings, uh, when they don't want
to do it anymore. And I mean,
I think it happens with every job,
but if you don't want to do it
anymore and you're a printer,
it's not like if you don't want to do
it anymore in your fighter. Correct.
So if you don't want to do it in,
you're a fighter and you kind of half
asset and you're in there with a guy,
you know,
like Glover to sharer Cantonese Smith.
I mean he's in there against dangerous
guys that are trying to kill hungry lions.
Yeah. It's just, it's a bad place
to be. It's a bad place to be.
You, you gotta be all in, in this, but
it's not a sad thing because, you know,
like that ridiculous safety for,
uh, the Seahawks retirement.
Cause they had some neck issues.
He tried,
he tried to figure out he's a pro
baller and he retired after eight years.
I went, Damn, eight years.
That's a good run, man.
I like how long is were shot been
fighting that the fucking run man. Dude,
he won that season one. Season two as
a heavyweight. The heavyweight. Yeah.
Remember he fought bad. Brad,
what was this bread? I am
proud. I am so that's right.
Right. And then remarried his fight after
that with uh, Sean Sam Salmon. Dana.
He goes,
Dana was give them a stink cause the
fight was boring and then just tack and
fucking,
we knocked out chuck Liddell.
That was like the first and
he did this to his heart. Yep.
I remember this time out with
one punch dude. The special,
when I think about Rashad,
he was so special to me and my career
because he was like in our camp and he was
like, the guy when he won the belt,
I marriage train with this one.
The belt came back and it was
the first time where like,
he would speak truth to us because
at the time I had a girlfriend,
I was super in love with it. I didn't
want to leave and go to training camp,
all this stuff. And he's like, dude,
how old are you? I told him, he's like,
I'm telling you it's gonna be different,
man.
You got us make decisions now based off
this and you just drop knowledge about
the professional life of fighting. And I
remember when he won the belt, he goes,
uh, he was sitting down. He came back
like a week after training and I go, dude,
fucking crazy. Or did you just feel like
out of this world I feel the exact same.
Nothing feels different. I
feel the exact same. He goes,
it's cool and you want this goal and
your achieved and I have the belt and he
goes back to work, man. He goes, I thought
I'd feel completely different. He goes,
you got to get better now. I gotta
get better. He goes nuts. It's,
I feel just like you do, man. It
felt right before I won the belt.
He fought Machida when the Cheetah
was Machida. Machida were there too.
There was a time for a couple of years
where Machida was just put it on piece
scares Gann UFC for awhile.
He was such a weird guy to fight man,
because he'd be like doing this.
Yeah.
He'd be doing all this weird movement
and then he would blitz in on you.
Nobody knew what to do.
Knock out power man.
That in his last fight with v
tour like good low, those uh,
one of the best knockouts.
So see pulled that up.
Pull that Leo Machida Kaos Vito
Belfort and now he's in Bellator belt.
We're making some waves, son and
saucy over in Beltour, right. Saucy.
How saucy things going to get to
whatever. Be Tours on thing. Proof,
sleet type Sausa
look like Ryan Gordon. Dude,
how bad is it right here.
Let see how he's almost too
respectful. Oh, he knew me. This,
he just, I mean he was out
cold. I'd almost rather have
you set up right. My knock.
I know, right? Let's, Ooh shown
like this is embarrassing.
This makes it more
embarrassing. Hands on. Yeah.
And then now he's fucking, his eyes
rolled back. Yeah. Damn. And then,
and then I guess the UFC,
I want to see that.
Wanted to work with them a little bit,
but he just went to Belk toward cause he
goes, you saw it as a way to strike, man,
I'm out. That's what I'm
talking about. Let's see.
Can we see in real time or they only have
it here? Look at this man. Look like,
fix that. Boom. One more time.
So what's interesting is like v tour
always would talk about standing square.
You know when I first started trading
Carlson Gracie's in 1996 old school,
it was before Vituro made his UFC debut.
That's when I first started Jujitsu
and feed tour was 19. The feed him,
he was always talking about um oh, here
it is in real time. Look high moves man.
Liotta so sneaky. Look at
that. That is phenomenal.
Let me give me that one more time, son.
In real time. He gets down on his knees.
Leo Machida,
the way he's moving here.
So slacky I mean he didn't
even see that comment. He's,
he's looking at these crazy hand
movements. I remember before this,
he beat on a Andrews who's a big up
and comer football player at Alabama.
He beat him. Start v Toilet. Yep. I'm
out. Yeah. Now he's at Bellin Story.
You get Roy McDonald. Gigger. I'm saucy.
There's some fun [inaudible] his
brother over there to test the waters.
Like tell me pee Pete.
How's it going bro? What kind
of car? What kind of toast?
And they get that Ryan Bader rematch.
There's some cool fights. Yeah.
Especially if they let them get saucy.
I mean he and he's 40 years old.
Do I think the other scary thing about
Bella tours that dad's on days on days,
that dead zone, where the fuck they're
going to call it is given them,
they gave them a nine figure deal.
Who did you remember about this?
Does zone deal? I don't know
what you're saying. Does,
oh hey z n what is that?
It's their streaming service,
so now they signed with them.
So now Bella Tor,
you remember how they had tape delays?
Now you can stream it digitally for
ff you get that now for five quality.
I think you have to pay for
it just like much. I Dunno,
but you can stream it on your phone.
First ones can be free.
Their first like welterweight
big fight is going to be a free,
everybody wins in Beltour deal
with days into stream live events.
So thinking about who they got right.
Okay. The Guy Gay Guard who uh, they,
his people just contacted me. I'm going
to get gay garden saucy on the podcast.
He's fighting Roy McDonald.
So they got gay guard.
They got Roy McDonald to absolute world
class fighters. Absolute world class,
top of the food chain. Maybe the best one,
85 and the best one seven in the world.
Certainly in the argument,
right then Shit, you know,
grind baiters never looked better.
Ryan Bader has never looked better.
He might have to wait Terman right.
Man, I'd ever beat Jon Jones,
but he's never looked better. You know
what I'm saying? Phenomenal. I mean,
he looks fucking incredible
and he knocked out King Mo.
He could be heavily champion, could be
heavy. He's light heavyweight champion.
Right? Who knows, man. Maybe him going up
to heavyweight would be better for him.
I mean, maybe it doesn't
have to cut weight. Maybe you
could fight more trimming,
especially as an older, as an older guy
in his thirties if he can beat Mitrione,
that says a lot. Well, he's really
gotten better and better and better.
You never stop getting better.
Then of course you got Paul Daily,
one of the most exciting motherfuckers
in any weight division who's got out
nuclear missile for a left hand.
Michael Van and page phenomenal.
Who did Paul well, Paul [inaudible],
his last fight with Fitch was
brutal. Man, that doesn't fit.
Fitch is going to Fitch.
Okay, but why make that fight?
That's what I'm saying. Why?
Why do that? That's fine. What are
we doing? How would you diminish,
why would you diminish daily like in,
in terms of what he was
marketability after the Larkin fight,
so he chaos Larkin who lark and I was
felt like it was a dark horse at one 70
especially after he fucked up Neil,
Maggie, Neil, Maggie. I was like, dude,
this guy is just, he's got
a lot of weird skills, man.
Larkens got a weird way of moving.
He's got that oblique kick that he
does to the body and he struggled in
Bellatore came over there, you
know, he's fine with Lima, Lima,
the motherfuckers [inaudible] him.
Lima beat them,
but it was close to in a row and
then he got chaos. Yeah. See Man,
you and us ones last semester. You're
in a slug fest with Paul Daley. Dude,
that dude has got something crazy
in his left hand. But you know,
after doing Paul Daley
and Michael Bennett Page,
Paul Daley signs new Bella tore contract
except Joe shillings call out. Oh,
Jesus. Joe Schilling.
Dan in MMA. Yes. Joe.
Cylance shillings fighting MMA.
Now Paul does not taking anybody down.
They're going to stand. That's
interesting. It feels kickboxing match.
I'll be more excited.
But do you think Paul Dale is gonna try
to take them down after all the shit he
talks about guys taking him down? I don't
think there's a chance in hell. Yeah.
[inaudible] Joe Schilling
fighting kickboxing,
one of the best kickbox in the world.
MMA tough for him.
He wants to fight him and may now
that's what he's doing. I'll watch it.
Here's the problem that Joe's been having
is they don't give them enough money
and kickboxing,
Bella toward kickboxing even.
It's just not materialized cause he's not
with Gloria anymore. Right. He's belter.
Yeah, I know. But he was in Gloria
or no? Yeah, he was in glory.
And then he came over to Belle tore a
couple of years ago and he's fought well.
He said, I love you. I loved watching
him. Fuck kickboxing for whatever reason,
Bella tore kickboxing just
does not have the appeal.
Can you call it doesn't have the
appeal. That's crazy to me, man.
I do not understand. I do not understand.
Really. I do not understand. I do.
Boxing is popular. How was kickboxing
not pocket? I don't know. I,
I've watched Bob time much
rather watch southern kickboxing.
Did you watch Rico Verhoeven's last fight?
Sure did. Fucking, that was amazing.
It was cool against, uh,
I'm not stopping my plan,
Ben Siddique you're not stopping.
You're Friday night for it.
I would if I didn't have shit
to do. I know, but, but yeah,
but have shit we've done. We've done
glory fight companions. Halfly. Yeah,
I did a glorified companion with
Joe Schilling. And who else did it?
I was in here. Well listen,
you would've been here. True.
I never miss fite campaigns. You're
going to make fun of the things I love.
Like I made fun of your soccer. I see.
Where do we go? Full comment down on me.
Full Circle, sir. I got to find
something to eat. I love kickboxing.
I enjoy kickbox and I think
Gloria puts out the best product.
I think Gloria is phenomenal.
I'm actually bummed out that lion fight
is not on a access TV anymore. Yeah,
they lost their deal with access TV.
Well,
if you've done fake plants for land fight,
probably still be around. So did one.
No, no, no. I think we only did
Gloria Phi companion for glory.
Bam. Joseph. That's right.
Eve Edwards and Joe Schilling Son 2016
so I would have done it since then.
She didn't have time, man. Okay.
Just cause it's kickbox love it,
but you would fucking down for, you
know, but we only did one Bella tore to,
we only done one belt tore ever. The
hope was that it was a big belter. Yeah.
Who was that? Who was fighting?
It was all Kaos and submissions.
It was amazing. An amazing card. No,
Shane hasn't bought borough dare you shut
down your mouth. Jamie. Jamie was like
fucking to work. Dare you.
Shamed car when she goes.
Never fought Bella toys.
No bench.
You son of a bitch name
came to my head shaved.
I apologize. I'm thinking, who the fuck
was, it was a big belt door. It was you.
Me and Eddie did.
It was phenomenal night.
Was it fade or [inaudible]
98 but it's not. Who Was it?
Fatal war fade or Frank Mir.
Oh yeah. Bombs on bombs. On bombs. Yeah.
Fade Frank Mir was chaos.
Yes. Good night. If you know Frank
Mir. I really appreciate that guy.
I appreciate the way he thinks and
talks about fighting too and one of the
things you said is like remember
fade or a hip toss them,
slammed him on his back and he said he
just got up and just wanted to swing at
him. His Ego got the best of
them and that wasn't the plan.
The plan wasn't just recklessly
abandoned and gauge on them. Yeah,
but he almost beat him. He almost
beat him. He had them wobble.
Well this is the thing I think
fade or gets you into his groove.
Like he did that with our live ski.
He's done it with a lot of people.
It gets you into his group with any in
any cracks you would send them over.
He's done it to Brett Rogers
but I think that I was,
I was curious to see how that fight was
taking place because in the beginning
frank was catching up.
He called rushed in,
but frank also said ring routes
is real. Like he's like, dude,
I need the experience.
Like I haven't felt that kind of like
nerves and stuff going to fight in a long
time. Like it's been a long
layoff for me. He's like, yeah,
as long as he been off two
years, two years. He's like,
I just need to get back in there.
Yeah.
What do you don't just they mine that's
supposed to sign with them with belter.
Scott Coker is on the phone with Barnett
and they've worked together before.
So you know that boy Barnett
gets in there. Molly,
Mario Batali's in the kitchen
right now making some salt.
He's chopping up some basal
and some garlic. Fucking right.
Let him for they're heavyweights.
Get saucer.
Let them get sauce on net saucy against
Ryan Bader. Well, who do they have?
They have bater. They
have just zoning. Uh,
Chael Sonnen, um, Frank Mir.
Remember when Frank Mann,
when Josh Stop Frank Mir actually realize
how good Josh's Josh the nightmare.
It's a nightmare.
I remember we beat the brakes off.
Roy Nelson beat the shit
out of him for five rounds,
beat the shit up and
showed some serious cardio.
Serious cardio to do that for five rounds.
Yeah.
Josh is a nightmare for all those
dudes. Oh, he's phenomenal. Yeah.
He might be Bellator heavyweight champion.
He could special if you let the man sleep
in, you know what I'm saying? Kind of
like went into, oh, just trust it.
Don't hate on them. Just look at it.
It's all yellow and it's all healthy.
Older would just skills for days,
leave him alone. Yeah. That's the problem.
When those old dudes get ahold of
that juice, they got all that year,
those years and years of learning and
experience and then all of a sudden the
body starts moving like
young man's body again.
That's why t r t v toward
was so fascinating to, he
might go over to bell too.
I wouldn't be surprised if,
well he might tell him with Ryan,
but he might go to bill. But if he
goes to that door for a detour is like,
he's like, dude, you know, you
guys touched a little bit. I don't,
I only want that bell tours dies. It's
too strict for me. I don't want that.
Well, that was one of the things
that, um, Rory, I'm not Rory, um,
that uh, gay garden was Saucy, was talking
about guys fighting him. Who was he?
Who was he bringing up that he
would need extra testing from?
He was just talking about this gay
guard was just talking about this.
Like someone will five or 85
at 85. Who Was it? Machida.
That's Rao. Machida. Yeah, that's right.
Because he lost a decision
to mature over in Bellator.
He wants extra drug testing for
Leo to Machita. They rematch.
I don't trust that guy said, whoa,
bell tours are going. No problem man.
The we checked. Yeah, we like sat on, it
looks like pee tastes like p set up once.
We did it twice.
The auto confirm it's PPN tastes.
We let them know six months in advance
when he's going to be testing the heads
up. He's getting tested a lot. Yeah.
We post dated all must get samples.
He has a full schedule. You want it
to look, we have 12 urine samples.
We took them all on the same day,
but we've got them.
That's what they need to do,
man.
Even that's too strict for
fucking be toward though. Hey,
have you heard anything about Tony
Ferguson? How's his knee doing?
I don't know what is going
on with her now. Eddie.
Eddie Bravo just had shoulder surgery a
couple of weeks ago. He just took his, um,
I think actually a week ago
just took the stitches out. Yes.
Bad from an episode because I remember
last time I saw him torn his story.
He's like, he's going like this
back. I'm good man. I'm good.
And he's doing this well,
it must not have been good.
He must've done something to hurt it
again and realize he just should go ahead
and bite the bullet and get the surgery.
I need to get them a sim styles or
whatever the sem stills. I need them.
Stem cells in the left team.
Dagestan braking.
If the negotiate negotiations of on
the fight. Okay, this is Russian.
A translation team could be versus
notorious MMA will not be achieved.
Then next week UFC announces fight
team could be versus Tony Ferguson,
x t UFC two 29,
October six.
How can he come back that
quick? Wait a minute. Wait a
minute. Wait a minute. Phil.
You know, real, I mean, MMA
team Dagestan that doesn't
work. Yeah, but wait a minute.
Let me think of like when Tony go to
Tony Ferguson's, uh, Instagram show,
I'm like break dancing. Right? When
did Tony Ferguson have a surgery?
That was before Brooklyn. Before Brooklyn
was what, how many months ago? Was that?
Two months ago? Correct. There's no
way. How's he do that to and from,
from four months. I hear controversy.
Khabib is happening. Yeah.
Fucking happening this year. That's
really, that's what you're here.
That's what the,
that's how the UFC gets him out of jail.
I said this and I don't
think they give up. I mean,
there were find out what's going to
happen in, uh, in July, right into the,
so there's go to these, uh, just
go to the actual images. The, yeah,
go back and then scroll down.
Let me see that one right there.
The words moving around or is the video,
let me see that this is him recently.
Hmm. That's fucking slow. Yeah.
He's just controlled. I mean,
Tony's an absolute freak, so when he's
ready to go, he'll be ready to go.
But it almost hurts him because he's
such a freaking, he wants it so bad.
He might not be ready. Right.
And he might hurt himself,
but he's gotta be with state of the art
guys. Ma'Am. It's Tony Ferguson thing.
Was that one up there with, so he's
doing that one right there. No, right.
You just had it. There
you go. Look at this.
So he's getting on his knees and
crawling across mats. So this,
this does not totally live very
guy who's ready to fight though.
It looks like he's just breaking down
scar tissue. That'd be a little strength.
Flexibility, motivation,
creativity, increasing tremendously.
Not 100% but close
champ step seven weeks out, 11 weeks
out. That's not much time, man.
That's not even three months.
That's a weird thing. It's
like, you know these guys,
they have incredible willpower and in
incredible endurance and incredible like
just the focus and drive and discipline
to get better. But your body has to heal.
If I'm the UFC, I'm paying to an open
house. Stem cells work. But if I'm Dana,
I'm paying for Tony. See a stem
cell doctor every week. Yeah,
no way back work. That would totally
help. I mean maybe it would help.
I think everything helps a little bit,
right? It's amount of what, how much is,
it's not like you could really measure it.
Like you've got a body chart where it
can look at your diagnosis is and go,
oh yeah,
look after we shot the stem cells in,
look your number here from fucking
fruit rollups oh yeah, yeah.
I mean I'm sure he's,
I don't know what he's doing.
I would assume he's doing something.
I would do growth.
I'll do a shitload of growth,
which you might get flagged to.
I don't know what they're
doing with testing,
but I don't think he could
really test for growth. Um,
I'm honest with you have to do bloodwork.
I don't think they're really embed a man.
I think it's real,
real iffy whether or not they
can catch you doing that.
The Igf one to get to growth and its short
half life, you have to do blood work.
So I don't know how they test these days.
How do they test and
they randomly show up.
They get blood in urine or just
have no idea. They've never done,
I still have those guys could
probably get away with it. Correct.
That's such a dangerous move.
If they flag you with it and
then you're out for a year. Yeah,
but if I'm injured and I have a doctor's
prescription for HGH to recover,
I'm doing all that HGH stem
cells with the UFC allow,
you can't even have a fucking ivy like
while he's going through all this,
he can't take an ivy blame.
Is that give you Phil's
dehydrated health still terrible.
What do we do about this?
What if he wants to get an Ivy Nad drip,
which will help them recover?
I know.
What if he wants to get a IV in
that's not even like outlawed,
but if he wants to get IV vitamins
like vitamin infusion, you can do that.
But for the,
if you're then the UFC business,
why wouldn't you want that guy to be on
all the HGH you can get just to recover
so he can fight cubby to fight for one
55 which were all vying to see. Yeah,
that's good for business you to say
flying. Fuck what he's, how he's doing.
You'd want him for sure on
the stuff that you can do,
like platelet rich plasma or you know to
send them down a Panama fucking like a
David Lee Roth Song. Panama. I agree. Dot.
But the thing about Panama and go into
like Dr Neil Riordan and doing all that
shit that a Mel Gibson was talking
about on the podcast with his dad. Yeah.
That stuff's legal. So legal in
Panama, you go down there and they'll,
they'll do shit that Tj went down
the road, gone down there twice.
He's gotten in there twice. Illegal
teacher's doing, it's legal.
It's totally above board.
You're allowed to do it.
I'd fly that fucking doctor in here
and I'd have it. You can't do it here.
You have to do it in Panama because
they're doing things that aren't legal in
the United States. Well, all right.
Either way. Private jet Tony says,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm saying anyone gets hurt.
We got this covered. This is
not enough money though. She,
the thing he said to the UFC made more
money last year than ever before. Right.
It's like a record year. Okay. A
lot of it was like all these deals,
but do you know how much money they
must have to pay every month? That loan,
they have $4 billion purchase.
That's so much money.
They just signed a few fucking nut
with ESPN in the streaming deal.
European plus.
But do you think they have enough money
where they could fly guys down to Panama
every time everybody gets hurt. All
500 and we're not, I'm not talking,
I'm talking about special treatment.
I'm talking to Tom Brady.
If I'm the New England patriots, I'm
flying down there by any means necessary.
Okay. When do you take it
off? When do you not allow it?
Do you let Michael Kia fly down there?
Nope.
You're shaking your head no.
No Dad. He strangles pedis? No.
Oh, was he raised? What's he
rate you sign up for a bit.
We'll have to find out.
It's also Pettis has an executive in on
Kevin Lee send Kevin lead down there.
Probably the same. Kevin
[inaudible]. Kevin Michael didn't,
he choked him out.
Denny.
He didn't tell me and the kids
got a lot of star power to it.
Doesn't mean I'm like a
shitty promoter. Yeah, no.
Kevin was levels to this game where like,
like if Lebron gets hurt,
we're flying them some. Yeah.
Michael Kassan. Number nine.
Kevin Lean number five.
Okay. Do you fly down Dustin?
Poirier Ooh,
you don't write
these fucking guys. What am
I [inaudible] numbers? No,
he's lost two. We're not playing.
Ah, you don't fly him down.
Maybe he can find to now fight nights.
Can you try to replant and get a bunch
of them in at one, sir? Listen. See,
now you're talking to Michael Johnson
from the Michael Johnson fight with Justin
Gagey. He gets flown down for the rest of
his fucking life. Check brain cell. Yes.
We're going to go through the ears.
Check brain cells.
I'm going to get them to lie with his
head on one side or fill his ears up,
let it soak into his brain.
You know there's holes in his ear and
then let him lie down on the other side.
Fill them up with stem cells.
Just go right through the nose.
We're going to the whole body. I
mean I'm giving Khabib, Connor, Tony,
Eddie Alvarez and Nate Diaz the fucking
frequent flyer card in the bitch.
Do you know that? Um, that's something
that, um, Kyle Kingsbury said he did.
He did some sort of nasal exosomes.
Right?
And that w do you remember
him talking about that?
Did you talk about that on the
podcast or off the podcast?
He's into all kinds of crazy jacks.
State of the art shit. Oh shoot up treat.
He's a big fella.
That's a big fella.
Cow Box checked super athlete too.
Does everything to try and
get the best body possible.
Well now that he works at on it too, like
that's his job. You know, it was on the,
on top of everything new that's
coming out. What can help and what,
what's the newest, latest, greatest shit.
So you're saying he injected testosterone
bright into is, I don't know. I,
these exosomes with that I think is the
shit that makes a stem effective into
his nose. Was he talking about
there was had Ben Greenfield,
God dammit hang out with,
he was Ben Greenfield. This
is why I think it was okay.
Now I remember in Greenfield,
Ben Greenfield crashed his bike
hard and really hurt himself.
His nose. Yeah. He hurt his head.
And uh, one of the things he did,
that's who it was,
one of the things he did to mitigate
CTE is have exosomes shot up his nose.
He did it.
I ve had it done up his nose and he did
like a full body exosomes treatment.
Help do it, isn't it? Did
you know Ben Greenfield is,
I've listened to you gotta have
him on your show on fire. Zippo.
Yes. First of all, he's a super
genius. Tell Brian is shut the fuck up.
Always talking to, can't I feel like
shouting Brian's pile rocks? No,
but he's also a super athlete.
Like he does a lot of crazy shit,
like tough mudders and all that stuff,
but he's on the ball when it comes
to the latest and greatest stuff.
He did a whole article for,
was it Esquire or when he shot his dick
up with stem cells and talks about all
the different things he did to his dick.
Oh really?
PRP and stem cells into his deck.
Yeah.
Any self administered as Dick has like
Gil's now and he's a super genius,
but Brian will teach us to Brian,
shut the fuck out or leave them at home.
I know. Tell Brian we don't have
the podcast. Do you know the,
the French Alps where they train us gears?
Hey God damn it.
This may talk just today. Please let
them tell them. Go. Please don't die.
I went Benzie ards, wind him up and let
them tell him drop science on me dude.
That dinner at the posted with
all those smart people. Yes.
Trying to solve the world crisis
or what was going on there.
And where'd you guys eat?
Eating, talking shit.
Like you talk shit like we talk shit.
Probably no date. They're smart guys.
Smart Shit though, right? Oh, there's
some shit talking. Especially it,
Sam Harris is very funny. Believe it or
not. Yeah, he's very smart dude. Yeah,
he's real funny. Fucking Weinstein is
very funny. Uh, Peterson was there, right?
Yeah.
And Jordan Rubin.
Dave Rubin rather is Dave Rubin's a
standup and then Jordan Peterson can be
funny sometimes.
He's a just insanely smart though.
Does one person start the topic and then
you guys go around like a round table
now?
We were all just talking and then some,
sometimes we're all talking
together in a couple of times.
Broke off in a separate
conversation was a lot of people,
you know those big dinners are tough.
You don't to talk to,
you break off in groups who's close
to, you know? Yeah. It was fun though.
It's fun knowing people that are way
smarter than you. That's my entire friend.
All my friends are smarter. Well, I
thought about this element. Oh Wow.
Everyone's swearing. That's what you want
though. Yeah. You don't want to be one.
This was the smartest guy in the
group. You're fucking, that's not good.
You don't want to be just like, you
want to be the toughest guy in the room.
You don't want to be that
good training partners.
Also sneak tough training partners
get good. You know what I'm saying?
You don't wanna be the best fighter in
your gym. Well, really interesting people.
It makes you crave
interesting conversations,
makes you more interested in different
subjects. They motivate you the same way.
Like if you were trained with Brian
Ortega, you'd want it to be tighter.
You were motivated by watching them.
It's like I did a podcast,
I think Drinkin Bros with Matt best and
those guys and they're all super high
level military guys.
They're asking me about fighting or
whatever and we're doing our Dick Jokes.
I'm like, nope, hold on.
Cause I want to hear what they say about
the military because they have this
fucking that they're black belts and
military and all that combat experience.
So I flipped the script on them
as fucking fascinating. Well your,
your listeners are going to
hate this because they pray.
I know this but it went by in like
missions and how it goes down.
I'm so fucking fascinating man. It is.
I don't want to talk and hear them talk.
Have you ever done a podcast
with Jocko? No, I fucking, uh,
I don't know him at all.
I woke up early on the other day and
felt like a tweeting and be like,
what's up now? Bid. You welcome for
all your, what time are you up? Uh,
I think like four something, but he
posted, he was up at like five something.
I'm [inaudible],
he's been on the carnivore diet
before it was the carnivore diet.
He just eats steak. I look at
him, I think that steak, you know,
knows I need to have him on the podcast.
He would be a great guest. I know wheat.
I think someone goes, man, we need
to get Jocko and fire the kid.
And I put let's do it. And he
goes, he goes on their boots.
You got to figure it out. Yeah, just
get, I'll, I'll give you his number.
I'm just show. But uh, he's,
he's one of those dudes were you,
if you read his stuff enough
and pay attention, it will
increase your motivation.
Just will. He's the real deal.
You know, he has this video call.
You ever seen this video? Good. Here
we're seeing good. Please play. Oh my God.
How long is this going to give
you a rock hard boner. What is it?
A couple of minutes. Two
minutes long. It's tough to
motivate. One of my favorite.
I've watched this at least once every six
months. And I'm not bull shit. Really.
Yeah, we played it on the podcast,
right. Go a full screen and uh,
gimme some volume and don't start
it prematurely. You son of a bitch,
let it load up.
One of my direct subordinates, one of
my guys that worked for me, he would,
he would call me up. Are we positive
side? What's his background?
Navy seal commander man.
Say No more fam. Okay.
Direct subordinates. One of my
guys that worked for me, he would,
he would call me up or pull me
aside with some major problems,
some issue that was going
on and he'd say possible.
We got this and that and the other thing.
And I look at him and I'd say, good.
And finally one day he was telling me
about some issue that he was having some
problem and he said, I already know
what you're going to say. I said,
well, what am I going to say? You
said you're going to say good.
Uh,
he said, that's what you always say
when something is wrong in going bad.
You always just look at me and
say good. And I said, well, yeah,
when things are going bad,
there's going to be some good
that's going to come from it.
Didn't get the new high speed gear
we wanted. Good. Didn't get promoted.
More time you get back. Oh,
mission got canceled. Good.
We can focus on the other one. Didn't get
funded, didn't get the job you wanted.
Got Injured. Sprained my
ankle, got tapped out. Good.
Got Beat.
Unexpected problems,
good
opportunity to figure out a solution.
That's it. When things are going
bad, don't get all bummed out.
Don't get startled.
Don't get frustrated.
If you can say the word good,
guess what we meet?
You're still alive.
It means you're still breathing
and if you're still breathing
[inaudible] you still
got some fight left in.
Get up, dust off, reload,
recalibrate,
reengage.
Go out on the attack.
Gangster. Dude. When it
comes from a guy like him,
I know it has a different meaning
behind different meaning. Yeah.
When those guys speak, I listen. Then I
fee. I hear that sometimes when I run,
when I'm running hills and
listen, I'm tired. I just go,
good, go, let go. I'm tired.
Tired. Good. You're supposed to be working
hard, good fight with a girlfriend,
but good. Don't bring a bit.
It's having that attitude though.
Like making that switch in your mind to
just look at things at a different way.
Everybody can do that.
Everybody that's not unattainable.
When you listen to something like that,
the real beauty of something that inspires
you like that is you hear it and then
you can actually put into action.
But do you ever have a problem
being self motivated Joel?
Like I like the don't your mind.
That's fucking fantastic.
I've never been a guy who's been drawn
to the motivational stuff or, yeah,
I just never have been.
I've, I've never needed it.
I've been blessed in that regards.
I don't know what it is.
Even when bad things happen, I'm always
super positive. Always. No, that's great.
I see bad things.
I'm not comparing my bad situations
to fucking jock on the in ward.
Right. I'm talking whether it's
a fee one, I lost a fight. Um,
if something's going wrong, if it in
stand up and it's something business wise,
I don't get something. I'm
usually all good. I always have.
I'm usually pretty positive. You
are. You're very positive guy.
I think that's one of the secrets to your
success is that you look at things in
a good way and you have
confidence and you act. You know,
I mean I tell all these young standups,
I go Brenton Charles and doing
comedy for two fucking years.
You gotta look what he's doing.
This is what,
when an athlete goes after
something like you, you,
you have the work ethic of an athlete
and the mindset of an athlete.
But you're also funny.
See the thing about comedy is a lot of
people that are really funny or also
we're, we're were personal
saboteurs. We self sabotage,
we are impulsive a lot of times get
addicted to things is like real,
like the type of person that becomes a
stand up as a person who says ridiculous
shit.
They say things that as
socially unacceptable things
cause they know it's going
to get a rise.
They hang around with a bunch of other
degenerates like you and me hanging
around and you get,
this is a certain style of person,
like a Joey Diaz style of person,
but you are an athlete who has
those attributes. So for you,
like what I tell like young
guys in particular go,
this highlights the importance
of discipline. It doesn't
make you less funny.
That's a cop out.
Like a lot of people think that
discipline makes you less funny.
There's the comics have these weird cop
outs. Like you don't want to be a guy.
Works hard. You want to
be a guy. It's funny,
some guys are funny and it's
effortless. Yeah, that's nonsense.
Working hard in everything
should work hard in everything.
Everything you try to do,
you should put the more attention
and more focus you put on it,
the better you're gonna get at it.
Correct. I just don't want to be a loser,
you know what I'm saying? I don't want
to embarrass myself or people either.
They pay for our ticket and be like, Dude,
Jesus Christ. Well also you can do it.
You can do it. Correct. You know
you can do it. So if you can do it,
just keep doing it. Get better at it,
keep working at it, keep swinging.
It's a fascinating thing to do for
a living then. You know the best.
Fuck kidding me. But
discipline man. So I've, I've,
um, I've never necessarily had
a problem, self motivating,
but I've always drawn inspiration
from a lot of different sources. Yeah.
I'll go to the rocks Instagram page
every day. Every day. No bullshit.
Cause he's always hustling.
I see the Rock,
he's always fucking flying around
in a jet. He's always in the gym.
It's a little bit put the rockin splash.
But Kevin Hart, he goes, no, no, no.
He does too. They're really not on jets.
The jet thing is, I know it's money,
but when Kevin Hart's in the gym all the
time, that inspires me for sure. Workout.
He's constantly in the gym.
Doesn't mean I'm going to work
out because of Kevin Hart.
No going to work out already.
You're just like, fuck yeah,
like watching people kick
ass. There he is. Bam.
The Rye also like people to kick
in it. Like I, I don't hate anyone.
I root for everyone. Like I, it's almost
a problem. Why root for everyone? Yeah.
I almost think it was almost a,
it was my downfall as a fighter
and as a football players,
I would root for everyone.
I think anybody, I want
everyone to do the pudding,
but it helps me any comedy. Like I want
everyone, I want everything to be good.
Yeah. Like I did a show at the
ice house and they're like,
you need to open up for you.
And so I called Emily at
the comedy store. I'm like,
Hey, do you have to door guys who are
vying for spots? She's like, fuck yeah,
give me a list. So every show I, I'm
always trying to bring the door guys in.
That's because I'm like, how can I, you
know what I'm saying? It's like, yeah,
everyone to do well.
That's because when I look at like what
inspires me is like when you post a
video in the crowds in Idaho or
whatever, or Krista, Leah, you know, are,
are like the crew when guys
are doing like, to me that's,
it's trying to keep up with that.
I, cause I feel like I'm in this,
we're in this race,
right in this race together and everyone's
fucking beast and animals and you've
got,
you're going to fall back in the PAC man
be a loser and get eaten by these lines
or you keep running with these
monsters. Yeah. That's how I look at it.
Well it's a great attitude
to have in anything.
If you want the people around you do well,
it's a great attitude to have
with everything that's been,
it's one of the major secrets to my
success for sure is have a bunch of people
around you that are kicking ass and then
like helping them, helping everybody,
promoting everybody, letting everybody
know and encouraging everybody. And then,
you know, when everybody's doing great
and everybody's, it's just, it feels,
it's a good feeling for all involved.
When people go selfish and they only
want a good thing to happen to them and
they get upset of good things happen
to other people, that's poison, man.
That's jealousy doesn't work. It does
the opposite of work. It does. That's,
so there's a,
there's an actual quote about that,
that jealousy is one of the rare emotions
that achieves the opposite effect.
That an intense too because you intend
to like diminish someone by being jealous
of them, but in fact,
you diminish yourself.
You're putting the energy into things
you can't control and it does not matter.
Yeah.
I forget who made that quote,
but it's even uglier when it's jealousy
amongst friends and we all have seen it.
We've all seen, it's weird. It's a weird
thing to see it. It's weird to me. Uh,
when I was flooding, it was weird to
see people who, I won't mention names,
but we're all in the same group
and a guy who would be fighting,
you could tell they didn't want him
to succeed. I'm like, dude, we just,
we just went through an eight week camp,
like tough, tough. I'm like, Oh, you're,
you're jealous man. With his success.
It's not to, you can go on your own path.
That's a weird thing, man.
With comedy, we don't see,
I thought I'd get it way worse.
I thought people were going to fucking
hate me when I walked into the store,
laugh factory. But we, I don't see
it around there. And if I do it,
they're not say it to my
face. But what is it? Well,
it's also once you're proven to actually
be funny, you're in, it doesn't,
nobody gives a shit.
Everybody just wants you to be funny.
But if you were like some guy who was
like maybe an actor that was kind of half
asking it and people would come to see
you just because you were an actor,
but you weren't really trying. He didn't
respect, which we've all seen in the gas.
Well,
there's been a bunch of those people that
tried to get sitcoms back in the early
days and during the Sitcom days when
there was a lot of comics like that.
We're getting these deals and then that
they would do a sitcom based around them.
Very few of them ever became like a
Seinfeld or something like that. Yeah,
but they gave it a lot of deals.
Manville mental.
So there was a lot of actors who got
into comedy and put together like a quote
unquote act to try to get a deal.
Like they would,
they would do it because they
would look at it seeing like, look,
if they're just going
to audition for shows,
it's really difficult to stand
out from the crowd. I mean,
unless you look like Luke Rockhold
or you got some, you know,
you're the perfect Ryan Reynolds looking
fella. It's fucking hard. Fuck you.
And then if you're a girl,
like you have to be like really
hot or you have to be really big.
Like you have to, some has
to be funny about you, right?
Well if you're a stand up,
there's no rules. Like you can be
Ali Wong, you can be Roseanne Barr,
you can be, I mean there's no, you just
have to be funny like anybody matters,
right? So a lot of actors
looked at it like, oh,
I'll just put together an act and aw man,
stand ups
would hate them. Hate them. I'm sure.
Want to go well either because it's
within like it's whoever it is.
Let's say fucking John Goodman's
I started doing stand up right.
And he came on stage and I'm like,
go fuck, that's John Goodman.
Then after about three minutes like okay,
let's John Goodman,
they'll fucking do man. Well that
was Michael Richards. You know,
Michael Richards wasn't really, it didn't
really have a background in stand up.
He had a bass on. I didn't
know that. Yeah, he was like,
he would do like, he would,
it wasn't,
didn't have like an act.
He would do like he would fall down on
stage and play like he was doing Kramer
Character Kramer. Yeah.
It was very strange.
And I don't know if he did it for a long
time and then stop doing it for a long
time and then started doing it again
after Seinfeld. But before he had that,
you know, air quotes incident at
the laugh factory. Um, you know,
we'd seen him a couple of times and
it was weird. You know, it just, it,
it was like a really,
really famous open Mike night guy.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. Strange.
It was like a guy who's super famous but
really hasn't been doing it that much
because you're going up at
the laugh factor comedy stuff.
You've got to remember it's murder.
They're not booking those people.
So it's murder drone for
whatever reason you got in,
but you're on that line up
with Belper and you and delay.
You got to go up and the crowds used to
seeing high level fucking stuff. Yeah.
This was like what,
2006 or some shit,
when did all that go down with him?
Brian said was at the Improv
and drove trouble. Well,
I had gotten back to
the comedy store and uh,
I think it was Brent Ernst,
I think.
I think he saw it.
Yeah,
he was over at the laugh factory when it
happened and he came back. He was like,
he was like, Yo, I just left
the left factory. He goes,
fucking crane was up there
throwing the end. Bob and I
was like, Oh, what happened?
He goes, dude, it was crazy. He lost
his shit. He was getting heckled.
So we had heard about it.
But then when the cell phone
video got TMZ released that shit,
everybody was like, Oh God, set match.
Like this is a new thing dude.
Yeah, it was weird man. I was uh,
I was going sit in the belly room the
other night and I've never seen Brody
Stevens who stand up. I've
never seen them. And they
got up there and just again,
I, I, I know who he is,
obviously he's always running by Mercedes
and then he just came out like doing
crowd work and not using the
Mike and I looked at Sam, I go,
what the fuck's he doing man?
He's like,
you've never seen him like going to go
just watch. And it was so funny, man.
Forever. And it's just
fantastic. That does.
Crowdwork for he does was warm warmups
for so many television shows for so many
years that he's like super comfortable
just talking to people. Yes,
it was fucking done. A special came
out recently. I think it's on iTunes.
Oh really? Lie from the main room taped
it and the man doing that set this,
the Kinison set the spot. No
Shit Dude. That's so cool. Wow.
When did they do this? Just came
out recently. A couple weeks ago.
He was talking about
on stage did for them.
He can go around and he'll go Iowa
like, yeah, for my goes, there you go.
Moves on the explosion like Jesus
Christ. Man. It was so funny.
He's a weird guy.
I'll be here to 2:00 AM 10:02 AM I'm like,
what the fuck? That's how he kicked it
off. I'm like, what is going on right now?
Well his uh,
his style is so unusual because on paper
you would never understand where the
punchlines are. But then when you hear him
say you can't stop laughing. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like I was dying. I don't know
if he writes it or if he just does it.
I wonder, I'd like to ask him if you
write stuff down or if he just does it.
Just a few guys like
that that are just funny.
The way that like Theo's like that funny
the way they say shit like Theo says
shit that I could say the same shit.
It wouldn't be funny but he says it
and it's fucking hilarious. Yeah.
That's the kingdom out comedy man.
Like nobody really knows what
funny is until you hear it.
But there's also something, uh, Steve, uh,
Simone [inaudible] he
was saying, um, cause I,
I was telling him I go, he goes man,
your hair a lot and go yeah, I'm,
I'm trying to just jump on anyone shows
cause I want to make sure it's not my
crowd.
You know,
cause you got to figure out what's
funny cause you just played your shows.
I don't want to be that guy. It was who
told you that? Who the fuck told Jay goes,
everyone here is trying to get their
crowds. Here's when you're on the road.
Do you want your crowd
man? And I'm like, I know,
but when I'm here on make sure it's not
my crowd because I feel like the funny
uncle at the barbecue, if it's my crowd
right, you don't find out what's working.
Yeah. The Ice House, if it's my crowd
that, especially at as I've walked off,
feel like Kevin Hart, like blood
flow. That was a fucking a plus.
But then you go to the comedy
store and it's not your crowd.
Like that was a d that was a
fucking dudes. That's true.
But if you go to the ice house and it's
your crowd and you actually record it
and listen to it, you
can do, that's important.
You can tell what is actually gonna work,
what's not gonna work.
You can tell and then you can tighten
it up so you have extra confidence at a
place like the ice house to do
different shit. To me, what it's like,
it's like cross training,
like it's not a bad idea to do some
kettle bells and run some hills and do
Jujitsu.
It'll probably make you jujitsu better.
And I think just doing crowds were,
no one knows who you are is great,
but doing crowds where they
know who you are is great too.
And as long as you're paying attention
to get a different thing from,
from each one, yeah, you're right.
100% right. Yeah, it's, I mean the,
you also get different things from
different size rooms. You know,
there's certain things that will work
at the laugh factory in certain pockets
that won't work anywhere at calm. It's
so strange to me. It's a weird thing man.
It's very strange. Strange as it
gets you feel any different energies.
It's so cool. It's so fascinating, man.
[inaudible] you want to talk to him about
the comedy store and like the history
of it? Steve Simone just,
yeah, he knows a lot of shit.
Steve's been around for a long
time and couldn't be a nicer guy.
Might be the nice guy and he might
be the nicest guy that's ever lived.
Almost like this. Like a darkness
back there that I want. I want him,
I know on what's going on.
Well I push him. C'Mon he's,
he's open about his dad and I was like,
can we come from a good family?
It sounds like you come from a nice guy,
a good family.
Just one day it was opened up for, are
you in San Francisco? I wasn't. Yeah.
The cobb's cobb's is an interesting room.
It used to be the tiniest room.
He used to be like 150 people, a little
tiny room on the road, but it was so good.
Everybody wanted to do it and
then they moved to that place,
which is like 454 50 giant ass ceiling.
It's a big place. It's in crowd there too.
Damn liberal. Well that San Francisco
man, San Francisco, highly educated,
very progressive. It's you. It's,
you're doing a different kind of
comedy there. Did an abortion joke.
Ah,
they
didn't like it.
[inaudible]
that's Larry. I'm more of a reference,
but it did not go well. Yeah,
you can feel it. Yep. Is
there anything worth? Nope.
But you know what it is, is when you run
into a subject that people don't accept,
you gotta ask yourself,
okay,
does my sense of humor different than
theirs or did I do a shitty job in
figuring out how to get that subject to
them? You know, because some subjects,
like there's quite a few bits that are
going to be in my Netflix special that
when I first started doing them,
they weren't that good.
There was something missing. Like I knew
there was something there, but your,
you don't,
you only know so much when it's written.
You really find out what's good when you
try it on stage and then that's when it
sort of comes to life.
It's like I have almost every bit that
I've ever done written in some way,
but they're all rarely the
way I do them. Yeah. You know,
once you get on stage with it,
that's when you start fucking with
it and figure out how to do it.
More of an outline. Yeah. And then we'd go
on stage like, yeah, but it's, you know,
along the way sometimes it just
tanks, you know, that has to happen.
This isn't something I stick with
it though. Don't, that's so crazy.
This isn't what I tell you just
the other night man around.
They'll move it around,
but a good beating,
like doing it where it doesn't
work makes you just refocus. Like,
let me go back and look at this thing and
figure out why these people got upset.
Oh, you know what? If
I just do this first,
then they'll know where I'm coming
from first to let me get away with that
because they won't think I'm an asshole.
You know it's weird.
And you finish your especially finish
editing yourself. Yeah, that's uncommon.
Right. But I didn't have much to
edit in terms of like content.
It was just how much should I
cut out and wear what, you know,
what show was the best one?
That was what it was really a lot of
the best one was the first show I heard
Tony, as soon as you guys get done, cause
I text you in a text on and he goes,
I don't even know why we're filming the
second one. I'm my mouth. The first one.
It really is. Yeah. Out of the park
Paul slugs. It's fun man. Wilbur Wright.
That Wilbur theater is
amazing. That places, you know,
cause it's like a theater but it's
also like a comedy club cause it's like
there's 900 or 1100
people in the room and uh,
I think it's like 500, 300,
300 or something like that.
Yeah. Reminds me of the palms if feel
you've come kid, the palms, the palms.
It's like people who are
right on top of yet. Yeah,
they're right on top of you were most
theaters so far. You can't feel it.
Katt Williams did the palms
one time when we were there.
I didn't get a chance to see him
though. God, he's fucking, he was there.
I think he was there like the day
before the UFC or something like that.
My brother went and saw a Kevin Hart.
He was at Pepsi Center. Oh yeah. I God,
I wonder how, how the fuck do you pull
off? Stand up the Pepsi Center. Jay Goes,
I know. And my brother's a little
bit of a hater by nature. He was,
he can't be that good. And I'm like, dude,
he's like the most successful
comic ever touring in the stadiums.
I bet it's pretty fucking good.
And he goes in there and he was,
I'd like Brown stage like three 16 he
goes, dude, it was incredible. Best.
Best he's ever seen. Wow. Which is crazy.
So fucking power house man power is,
or how hustling performance powerhouse.
Yeah.
Interesting. Right. It's interesting
when you see those super winners,
those super winners that just pushed
the envelope of success. It's weird.
You know those,
those qualities are very strange.
It's also strange in comedy
because someone, Kevin Hart
might be Your Cup of tea,
but then they might hate bill burr, which
it's very strange to me. That's silly.
Why don't I shouldn't say hey. You
know what I'm saying? Like, yeah,
like bill burn might be just okay to you,
but Kevin Hart's your number one. Yeah,
but that's okay.
That's normal.
There's always going to be people
that have different tastes.
That's that same with music. That's the
same with four shirts. Everything percent.
Yeah.
It's crazy time for stand up though.
If you think about how many different
comedians are really good right now and
have specials, it's nuts.
Netflix is blown up,
blown up.
Do you know Russell Peters was the
first comic to get a Netflix special?
When did he get is a long ass time ago.
We heard him in an
interview talking about,
I think it was with a sway in the morning
and he goes out as the first one and
they say, how much did they pay you?
And he talks about it. He goes, ah,
he goes 10% of what Chris rock got paid.
And they looked at him.
And when was he the first one?
What year was it? Old School.
Really find that look good on a Russell
Peters comedy special prosecutors is a
monster.
I had one on Netflix in 2005 I
think Russell Peters beat Ya.
Probably if he was first.
Pretty sure he said he was first
two then five Goddamn Goddamn, I don't
even know Netflix was back then. Yeah,
nobody knew.
That was part of the problem.
It was like everyone was going on.
So when people like my
specials on c so I'm like,
oh fuck to what else is going on this
weekend with the UFC? What are the fights?
Are there? Well you got the ultimate
fighter finale on Friday. Prayers.
Are Any others on that card
style bender pull up. Ooh, style.
Brender I did Brad to
vars versus tile vendor.
Perhaps a motherfucker man beat him,
but I think I really love style Benner.
But uh, Brad's been quietly foreign. Oh.
But also Brad is a guy who the
rumors he's injured go on this fight.
He was going to call the fight off. He's
injured. Dare you say that online? No,
it's all over. It's as it, yeah.
What's he injured with? I don't know.
He's supposed to pull out, but he's
going through it. So it depends.
People forget bracket and
fucking wrestle too fucking.
That's a tough fight.
Fire style bender from Nigeria 13 and,
oh son. He's a motherfucker. He
really is. He's so exciting. Damn.
That's very good. Let me see the
right, the regular UFC card again.
That's a big fight. So that's the headline
fight. Yeah. And the ultimate fighter,
which is you see them, you see they're
selling the ultimate fighter house.
The title, the ultimate by selling.
They're selling it really. Five Mil son.
You want it five now. A good investment.
What did you just like 19 bedrooms,
p people peed all over that house.
Oh Dude. He would go on there.
It's going to smell like a dude's ball.
Do jacked off in the sun's out rom font.
That's a good fight right there.
That's a very good fine go con sacking
and Kaleel round tree fucking fight.
That's a real good fine Felder,
Mike Perry. That the fucking fight.
That's right. Do you remember an elder
at welterweight? Very interesting.
He's a big dude.
Felder has to cut some serious weight
to make one 55 Felder's a monster on the
Mike too. He's a great commentator.
Very Smart Paulo Kosta in Uriah Hall.
That's very interesting.
I'm not at 2.0 I'm not saying
Paul Coast has done all the drugs,
but how does he pass this fucking tests?
What?
Whose nose is clogged up for that sniff
test and his allergies are kicking in
that forgot their inhaler?
Like
how does the [inaudible] he's just
not live wherever his house is. Dude,
he is first team. All Landover
nod on that car to go down there.
It's close. Oh, what your car clothes and
Landover Nada. That might be the sleeper.
The night folks.
Yeah.
I get this phone once you've been
talking about that fight on fight pass.
That's crazy. Hooker and Burns is a
more fucking fight to Gilbert Burns.
Dan Hook or holy Shit.
What a card this is. Yeah.
To this card is insane.
Great Card.
This is an insane car cause people aren't
even talking about this hooker burns
fight. Dude. You know what's
going to be sad though?
I think the pay per view
numbers. Oh, how dare you.
You never know Steve paid versus DC.
It might get into twos 20 hundreds well
and a lot of people like Max Holloway
and Brian Ortega. You don't think you
can make it into the to do hell yeah.
200 200 be a nightmare to
50 was the last one, right?
Which is not good.
I see.
I'm hoping it does around five
to 600 make GSP fight again.
You need GSP back bring GSP. But he's
the last one. They get real good numbers.
He got eight 50 right?
I know,
but see I think this does around between
400 600 yeah. What do you think Jamie?
I hope so. Do you want me to wait face?
It's tough to tell these days, man.
I think they need to get rid
of the pay per view model.
It's obviously not working.
What do you think they should do?
I think they should put these on a,
on for free. I think Jewish Poland,
ESPN, these major fights. How
are you gonna pay people? Well,
the paper you model top four NBA guys
are getting more than the top 10 NFL
quarterbacks and those games are all
free. So there's one somewhere, right?
There's a model. That
model is not working. Yeah,
but NBA is way more popular than New York.
She was on the board,
but it's also free.
The sponsorship deals,
the endorsement deals or you know,
they have major endorsements. Right.
But there's only so many endorsements
that, and they'd get behind cage fighting.
You know, it's such a crazy dates
in for bud light Miller lite.
Like we've had some big more now. Right?
Yeah. Roughly the same amount of people.
Also like same amount of fighters. Same
on NBA players. About 500 yeah. Yeah,
yeah. There's no comparison in terms
of overall viewership though. Like,
what is a big basketball game? NBA
Finals. 35 million. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. 100 on it. Yeah. I'm
just salient view models.
So old school,
especially now with the illegal streaming,
me and Jamie were talking about
it. You know, if I'm not that guy,
cause I find I'm not trying
to steal money from UFC,
but there's a link I can go
to every time that's in HD.
I don't have to be a fucking
dime for really everyone.
So many of my friends do that.
I have so many people so they're going
to jail when uncle fester finds out.
So when the numbers are low,
you've got to take that in consideration.
18 to 36 males can figure it the
fuck out there. Not like $70 no.
I wonder, I wonder if you just had it
free if the numbers would be bumped.
I don't know man.
It's like you're going to make it.
You've got to make a big fucking risk to
do that because you've got to think of
how much money the U of c has to pay
every month to make that loan to make that
monthly nut that's on them. That's
not the fans prompt. That's true.
The other problem is think I'll expensive.
It'd be an MMA fan these days, so I'm,
I got to fork out money for ESPN plus
now just to watch how much does that,
was it nine 99 you could call it low
and five bucks a month. That's like,
I think it's 10 okay. Okay. Nine 99 so you
got that right. What does that go live?
Because fipass is still 2019 January,
so I've got to pay for that.
So that's money, additional money and
then paper views, there's one every month.
So if I want that, that's 70 so it's
$80 a month just to be a UFC fan.
Not following. Watch dies on, dies
on, dies on Bella tour. I got to pay.
How much is that going to be?
Nine 99 to watch the Bella Tor now,
is that what it is?
Let's say it's nine 99 less than that.
I'm assuming something's wrong
with the streaming service.
So if they just had a free streaming
service and then you had ads,
do you think they could make it up?
I'm sure what,
but my point is it's going to expense
would be an MMA fan and you're losing fans
and the numbers aren't declined.
So often there's a business model problem.
What if they made a deal with Netflix?
They tried that and no Netflix, Amazon.
Those guys didn't want to play a game.
They went and your audience isn't
big enough. Really? No, they went,
we'll Twitter will use the NBA.
We're going to the NFL route.
Cause the the other sports
too big. Hmm. Twitter.
What are they showed it on Twitter.
Can you get Twitter on your TV?
You could send, if you have it on
your phone, you could almost it. Yeah.
You can just send it to
the screen. Yeah. Yeah.
What is your phone runs out of
batteries in the middle of the fight?
Your friends call you pussy. We'll
plug it in. It's out linking.
It's up playing off your phone
directly. Now when you do it, I'm,
I do it through apple TV, but you could
do it through Google. Android, right.
You can do like Google play. You have
like a stick that sticks in the USB show?
Yeah, there's a little symbol.
Um, interesting. Sean up there.
I mean down all used to be science
fiction just a little while ago, but I,
I see shit on my like, uh, someone
sends me a youtube video to watch.
If I'm home watching
something on apple TV,
I'll just stream it right to the TV
set. That's amazing. Is that us? Oh,
well,
uh,
there's a little symbol like on the top
by the bar just broadcast to a TV thing.
It's just, I feel like UFC has
this old school model right now,
but with the UFC plus a ESPN plus it's
at least heading in the right direction.
But the paper, your model, especially as
expensive as is to be a fan right now,
they're making it tough.
I think it's going to come a time where
you're not going to need any streaming
service.
You just to be able to type of website
address into your television and it'll be
universal. Everybody will have that.
I think that's, that's real close.
Like a lot of people getting
rid of their cable. Yep.
Dish can't apparently young kids,
they never watched Katelyn ever. Yeah.
I'm a dish fan, but most young kids
don't fucks with any of them. Yeah.
Like what dish? What? That's
interesting, right? The only ass, Huh?
The only thing it's good
for really is live events.
That's everything else.
Netflix is more popular than broadcast
cable and more in TV viewing.
Hm. Hulu and Youtube
all, I think it's, wow.
The thing I read said it's got more
viewers than all of those combined. Wow.
That's accurate. Broadcast
Cable, Hulu and Youtube.
Netflix has more than everything.
See if Netflix got the UFC,
that would be crazy for the
UFC, for the UFC flakes. Like,
dude on it. They could, you know what
if they just said, we have so much,
like how much is your not
billion? 4 billion. Um, okay.
Gonna just write them the check.
We'll just buy it.
It's like a pair of sneakers that you
never going to wear and fight every day.
We don't give a fuck just there.
They could do it, man. I wonder.
Yeah, that would be, but then how would
you figure out how people get paid?
You'd have to give numbers, right?
It would have to be in the contract,
because that's one thing about Netflix.
They don't want to give away the numbers.
So if you have a comedy special on Netflix
and you ask them, hey, how's it doing?
It's doing really well. Yeah, but
you're really happy. Yeah. But you know,
because like you, they go, you want
to do another? You're like, man,
I must want it pretty well. Now if you
do a special on there and you're like,
how are we doing? Like all right.
Yeah. Keep on keeping on, man. Yeah.
Do you want to do another workout? We're
all set. It's probably didn't go well.
You don't have exact numbers,
which I feel like is a little hairy.
A little dicey because you have no
negotiating power. Yeah, Super Dicey.
Because if you're like, hold on, let's
say you for instance, you're like,
hold up 100 million people, watch
this, I need more fucking money. Right?
Like to them is 5 million watching good
is 100 million. Where are we at here?
No we negotiate.
That can't be right.
Like they can't be good but it's
their business. They started it. It's,
that's the thing is like
you don't have to do it.
They're trying to do it on HBO and then
you get real numbers or you could do it
on showtime and you'd get real
numbers or I could do it on Amazon.
Jeff Bezos tells you to go fuck yourself.
Do you think you're at a disadvantage
for your non Netflix these
days? Cause, cause here's,
here's my argument that I
had with Brian about things.
Shoot special is net don't give up.
Netflix is the king man. And if your row,
if you're, you, if your bill burr, if
you're Kevin Hart, if not Kevin Hart,
if you're fucking Chris Rock,
any of those guys, right?
They're paying you mass amount of
money and they're promoting it.
But if you get lost into that shuffle
because they have so much content now it
does pay off. I Dunno, you know,
I'm Gaffigan interestingly enough,
decided not to do it and he could do
it anywhere and he decided to do it on,
on all platforms.
So he doesn't have it on Netflix,
but he has it on a bunch
of different things.
So you see where Gaffigan put his
specialist, but he did it on his own site.
Right. And released it very Louie CK
style. Yeah. I think um, he actually,
I think it's available on Amazon.
I think it's available on a
bunch of different things.
He's so established though. Yeah, sure.
Dapkins that mother fucker people still
ask them to do is hot pockets. Yeah,
that's a good point because I think that
they probably, no matter where he goes,
his fans are very loyal.
They'll go seek it out.
He's one of the biggest in the world.
Yeah. But I'm saying if you're like,
let's say you're a guy like Brian Cowen,
like where are you gonna
get the most exposure?
Honestly Youtube the most exposed free,
which is be release it for free for three,
but that's very expensive to do.
He says Gaffigan's Nobel ape.
Initially it will be released on multiple
pay TV and digital platforms including
Apple's iTunes, Amazon video at
t and t charter communications,
Comcast Cox Communication, direct TV,
Holla at Directv dish network. Oh Shit.
Google play. And Sony playstation
says war rise almost. Well,
Walmart has rooted thing.
Microsoft's Xbox and album version will
also be released on the same day in
digital and physical formats.
That Emma fucker.
Good Fan Sizzler,
a $5 download via the Louis C K now.
Hm. Yeah. It's interesting. It's
interesting because I think that uh,
he could do it. So if he does it
and then it really works out well,
maybe Kevin Hart might do that
too. They might say, listen,
I could try it for 99 well, he can do
whatever he wants. He might be like, Hey,
I'm Kevin Hart. I could just have,
people are going to go watch my special.
I just don't put someone can do that.
Yeah. There's a small hand, if you're,
if you're a smaller level comic,
let's say B list,
you can't do that and make money. People
are going to see it. So maybe you get,
you get money back when you go on
the road. It's like, Holy Shit,
that was great and it's free. So we got
on the road and in theaters now maybe.
Well that's the thing.
Do you know how many comics I've done
that and had a youtube video that became a
giant smash and then we're selling
out theaters. What does that girl,
Angela Johnson, you know
Angela Johnson? Yeah.
She was on that TV shows at hilarious
bit about the Vietnamese girls doing her
nails. Yeah, that bit got on Youtube
and she was selling out crying Gel.
Yeah. Quit told jail. She's hilarious.
Very funny. Yeah, it's fucking hilarious.
She was selling out giant plays
to that extent and how that,
Christina is similar to that,
but Chris Delea on snapchat,
his videos were so funny. Yeah. It made
him insanely popular amongst other stuff,
but that's one of the,
you know, he had millions
of followers on there. Yeah.
So you go into a city and he's a brilliant
comic and you know these one in the
biggest of the world now. He's so silly.
He's a unique kind of silly, so weird.
Silly. You would hate us if you saw our
texts everyday about shoes and fashion.
Easy Dad shoes came out. I'm like, dude,
I can get you want a peer? He's like, yes.
And what are Yeezy Dad's shoes?
Jamie, you're going to hit well.
You might like him. You like him more
than the three 50 booths. Sweat these boy,
just sweat peas, boy, converse
with these balls. Dude,
I'm not so sterile. Red Suede. I
know I'm wearing these just for you.
When did you get those converse?
Send it to me. I would never,
I was going to say there's no way
you in a story. He sent me those,
but I put on my saw where these mother
fuckers, those are fucking daisies.
Those things. Those are
usually easy. Gee, dad shoes.
And you liked those San Jose sharks
fan? I do not. It's like a shark. No.
Let me just say this.
That was the first easy and I can,
I can get them to coming out. But I went,
I'm going to pass on a pass on those,
you know you to go Chris, you
want these. And I went, Chris,
these only good on small guys. He
goes, you're right, but I'm smaller.
I go with the right outfit in small
genes can wear mills. You're right Brent.
We're going back and forth and
you're series shot or serious.
I sent to Brian went fuck you.
Ah,
because Brian likes to wear those boots
to make him look like he's an Italian
painter. Correct. In
wishes. He is taller. Yeah.
He's got those boots with wooden heels
with leather soles that are really
slippery strand and they have
zippers on the side. So I'm like,
what the fuck are you wearing?
You're supposed to wear these when
you were in Catholic school. Like why,
why are you wearing this as a grown
man is 51 years old. He's crazy.
He never had a period of time.
We dressed like his age. Never.
He's like finally old as his dress.
Yes.
Like he is now the age
she's supposed to be.
He like got older and fell into is
establish wardrobe. Not anymore, bro.
Oh my God. No fuck is happening. That's
not, why is he dressed like a skater?
Wait a minute. Are those slides identical?
Him? Wait a minute. That's Brian. Dude.
That's fucking Brian's. Brian.
Count. Cool. Make that face bigger.
Very blurry dude. What's Brian
Cowen? And that's three sizes.
Here's leaving or those slides. Is
that black socks and slides. Oh my God.
That's Brian Cowen for special.
He wants me to dress him and I'm going
to get Tom Special. Don't, don't, don't,
don't let him be himself pulled. No, he
dress for where you want to dress, bro.
That's what I told that it's him. It
is him. There he is. Where's that?
Those are, those are black
socks and sandals or others. No,
they're not. Those are, uh,
those are skate shoes too.
Those wearing skate shoes.
Slow roll down those shoes.
I was hoping that those were
black socks to Asian style.
I thought they were black socks and slides
because they're so gross with a white
stripe goes over the top.
What are those slides?
Is that the property was black socks
type? Let's do it. Yeah, there you go.
Is that everybody does
it? Yeah. Tight Move Joe.
You can do it with slides but you
can't do it with flip flops. Correct.
Like slides and socks is okay? Correct.
Why do they have rules like that?
It's the streets bro. Know
what it is. It's gross.
If you liked that sock
in between your toe,
would that bar with a flip flop like
master splint or some shit like a Ninja do
that. Remember those Ninja
shoes? I'm Adam as well.
They called tabbies or something like
that. Oh God. Oh that's hilarious.
And everyone, dudes, you'd go,
Oh, where those kung fu shoes.
Do you remember those Kung Fu shoes?
Did you,
you didn't grow up in the east coast to
do now a lot of dudes in like the 1990s
and certainly in the 80s would
wear where Kung Fu shoes.
She just does whatever dress up. Like they
knew Kung Fu, my contents and parents,
those things. Oh, I bought you. Those
are Todd's, those are called pods.
Those are Kung Fu shoes.
Sun dews would where Kung Fu,
like they knew Kung Fu because they had
those shoes on and be like, Damn Dude,
I'm not mad. I was, oh shit.
Like those, those are different.
Those are the lives of more fashionable.
Yeah.
That's like the first ones
you show or some bullshit.
Somebody had a bit about it. About
dudes show, I think it was. Um,
do you remember that guy
that had a bunch of fucking,
he had a bunch of bunch
of specials on Hbo.
Robert Townsend. Remember
that? Remember Robert Townsend,
remember he had a bunch of a HBO specials
where a bunch of different comedians
on.
I feel like someone on one of those did
a bit of Kung Fu bit about dudes in the
ghetto who dressed up like
they were Kung Fu outfits.
I'll tell you who I don't fucking
trust dudes that were aqua socks.
What do you mean by aqua socks?
Like blue socks? No Bro. Aqua socks.
Like if you went to waterworld
or like a waterpark, aqua socks,
wearing them out in public,
do nothing drudged up fucking girl up.
Worse than Aqua.
A mood bring a fucking rare there.
You can still give him at
Walmart and shit. Who wears them?
My Dad wore them when I was a kid.
Those lawyers,
those you walk around with those
long. Yeah, I forget the waterpark.
So you attraction. Okay, that makes sense.
But dudes where I am in real life. Yeah.
Hmm. Like some asshole. You
didn't want to be a superhero.
Maybe they're just ready
for water at all times.
Like what is the purpose of those?
So you don't slip on the outside of the
pool yet? Cathol hot and shit. Okay.
To quit being a pussy.
How about that?
But those are like very similar to
like minimalist shoes. Those are cool.
So you bring up cool ones.
Fucking hold on. How was that?
Cause those are dope bro.
Like that. Well that's some shit you
would run in Sagwan. Yes, I would.
I know that's what I'm saying.
I'm talking about the original aqua sock,
but it's different. See that one right
there that you just showed that last one.
The last one. The one above that. The one
that looks like a normal sneaker. Yeah.
Like that. Like that. Yeah.
That's dealt those look very similar
to the shit I wear when I run some TVs.
I run the with those, uh, they,
they have like nothing to them.
They're still rolling with
those. Yeah. I love those dude.
My feet are way stronger
because of running that way.
100% made a big difference.
It definitely made a difference. Yeah.
Because your feet have to work way harder.
It's not like a,
if you run in a pair of like,
I like to run in like speed cross
shoes cause they got a lot of traction.
You could run on anything.
You don't worry about where step and
you just dump on Shit but you don't,
you don't,
your foot doesn't have as much engagement.
Like when there's no cushioning
at all and it's a thin layer,
your foot is like pushing
off and gripping some shit,
but you can't just jump strengthens
your feet can't go fucking full. No,
can't tie. No, I tried you little fuckers.
You get that plant. You got that planner.
I did that. Plantar Fasciitis is no joke.
Simon, son, I'm back to cushy shoes.
Yeah, easiest and shit. Oh, you like
those, but you don't run anymore, right?
I need some. I need, I need to
inject some shit and in my leg.
Oh fucking, well, I'll
tell you in my leg, dude.
I'm telling you they can do that now.
They're doing it.
They're doing every homeboys
around here, right? Oh yes.
They're doing all kinds of shit now on,
you know what else we should do
with your shoes? Don't cover that.
We should do it on air. We
should get a Nad drips. Yeah.
Maybe they'll do it in here and do it.
It's supposed to be insanely painful.
If you do the push nav
where it's like 15 minutes.
It'd be funny if we did a podcast.
It's supposed to make your guts wrench
like someone stomping on your stomach,
but if you get through it, you get through
it in 15 minutes versus eight hours.
Hold up 15 slow dreads and what to do.
It's supposed to be incredible
for anti aging. I'm down
for that. Yeah, 15 minutes.
15 minutes of like just the
worst podcast of all time.
I think it'd be a fun podcast because
for the rest of the time he'd be fine.
So like beforehand he'd be fine and
then for 15 minutes you'd be like, ah,
I shit my pants.
And then to do that for 15 minutes and
then how happy will be after minute after
it's over. You feel great talent
and they're making fun of us. Yeah.
Eating cheese and shit. No, you
can't eat cheese anyways says rise.
This is too bad. What? He just horrible
psoriasis. He can't eat cheese. No.
What's he eating?
He's on some weird diet.
Refused to take like the proper
medication. Which one of those guys? Huh?
Isn't it funny that he would make fun
of anti-vaxxers but he wouldn't take
medication? That's fucking crazy. He's
crazy. What medication does not take?
Does it fuck with him or something?
No,
he says that it solves it for a little
bit, but it's not complete problems.
My Diet. I'm like, dude,
whatever you're doing, just
use the goddamn ointment. Well,
you know, George, you'll see
the sunsets kid in Tampa, by
the way, this weekend. Oh,
where's he at?
Tampa and club and prompts arise.
This kid don't look down on them
from the third floor though.
Tamper and promise three floors.
Yeah, I know. Look down from the top.
You see that bald spot? Know
comfortable. You want to sit lower level.
You don't see his legs or his head bald
spot. Tampa Improv. That's a weird area.
That's like Igor City, right? Or Yeah.
Yeah. I was just there. Did you like it?
I loved it. Fun People.
Helia all Texas, man.
Jordan Peterson cured his
psoriasis with a carnivore diet.
He did that carnivore die. We'll all
he eats is meat. That's all he eats.
Red Meat and it got rid of
it. Yep. That's all he eats.
Like Brian should fucking try that, man.
Whatever he's doing, his legs are so bad.
Yeah, that's sucks, man. Just getting the
rise. This is a rough one. Stress too.
You know, he's torn a lot. Stress.
Even the traveling show coming up here,
this special Lotta Shit son.
So how many times you going up a week now?
Uh, last week I went up four times.
Damian? Yeah, at least three.
I'm stressed out.
I'm stressed out this week because I'm,
I'm on the road on Saturday,
Oklahoma and I'm doing a set the ice
house and hopefully a set at the laugh out
too. If I can make him. I
always, yeah, I always want to
be at the comedy store, man.
Yeah. Anywhere you can get up though,
man. Do you do the Hahaha at all? No,
it's a good spot. Goes on there. I'm
going to do, um, Neil Brennan has a,
a show at west side. Tom
and club, I think. Yeah, I
started doing that in Venice,
Venice, Santa Monica. Oh, okay. I heard.
That's really good. Yep. Me Too. Thanks.
Shalon was telling me about
close to, yeah, it's close
to you, right? Super close.
All right,
so anything else?
Is there anything else we need to talk
about before we wrap this pitch up?
Young Jamie covet it or anything crazy
that happened during the podcast?
You need to let us know about?
No, no. Crazier today. Not Today.
I'm in a, I'm in spoken next
week. Spokane, Washington. Okay.
And then first two weeks of August,
Texas. Can't get enough. I'm in Austin,
cap city and then Dallas
Improv second week.
Get you some Texas Addison Improv. That
one. Uh, no, I think it's Dallas Improv,
but it might be a in Addison. Yeah, it's
just outside of Dallas. Great. Tifo k.com.
[inaudible] DOT com. All
right, that's it. Uh, tomorrow
fucks month. Joey Diaz. Oh,
snow sheds, right? Tomorrow's
4th of July. We got a, Oh,
Josh Barnett sent me a text message.
He said I'd be more than happy to come
on and explain the whole deal with Usada.
Boom, boom. They shout out
to Josh Barnett. Shout out
to the war master. All right.
Uh, tomorrow. Joey D is 11 AMC. Bye.